Was?
Developers, Developers, Developers.
Developers, Developers.
Windows 11 ist Spyware.
Habe Windows Reverse Eng.
Das ist der Teufel.
Freue mich auf deine Worte dazu.
Also, ich glaube, man muss Windows nicht Reverse Engenieren, um zu wissen,
dass die auch für meinen Geschmack etwas viel senden.
Das siehst du ja schon beim Setup, wenn das Ding erst einmal
dich die meisten Sachen schon gar nicht mehr ausschalten lässt,
sondern nur noch auf Basic switchbar ist.
Du kannst ja, du musst ja am Anfang, wenn du Windows 11 installierst,
irgendwie, was weiß ich, zwölf verschiedene Fragen beantworten
und keines davon kannst du richtig ausschalten.
Moment, mein RGB, ja, jetzt RGB an der Tastatur tut wieder richtig.
Dann ist jetzt alles gut.
Ich muss die Klimaanlage anmachen, hier ist 30 Grad.
Nein, das kann nicht sein.
Also, laut meiner geflashten Uhr, habe ich euch ja gezeigt, das Teil,
das ist das China-Chinesen-Ur-Ding mit Custom-Firmware,
die zeigt an, angeblich wäre hier 30 Grad.
Das glaube ich aber nicht.
30 Grad ist doch etwas viel.
So viel hatten wir die letzten Tage über nicht draußen.
Wie soll es denn 30 Grad hier drinnen warm werden?
Ich tippe mal eher so auf, lasst mal kurz in mein Home Assistant reingucken.
24, ja, ja.
24 haben wir.
Aber 24 Grad ist nicht so viel.
Aber 24 Grad ist mir auch zu warm.
Dementsprechend werde ich mal meine Klimaanlage anmachen.
Welches OS soll ich nutzen?
Das OS, wo es die Software drauf gibt, die du brauchst.
Nicht, was nicht viel Möglichkeiten, oder?
Ansonsten Arch Linux, by the way.
Was sonst?
Arch Enjoyers.
Mal kurz die VM an.
Eine Runde Arch Linux Package Updates.
Die Tümpelmusik ist ein bisschen laut.
Ja, besser.
DOS?
Nee, DOS ist nicht so gut.
DOS ist nicht so gut.
DOS ist das Einfachste.
DOS-Box funktioniert wunderbar.
Als wenn du wirklich ein DOS brauchst.
Für was?
Dann ist das unter Linux tatsächlich kein Ding.
Package Updates.
Aber ich glaube, du willst mich gebaiden.
Wer braucht denn DOS heutzutage?
Tagtäglich für was denn?
Hier.
Keine User-Repo-Updates.
Was ist da los?
Die anderen Package-Updates schon alle durch?
Das geht aber nicht.
Das geht aber schneller, als ich gedacht habe.
Egal.
Ja.
Ja, nur Steuercomputer von der Bahn.
Oder irgendwelche Computer bei der Bahn.
Windows 3.11.
So, schauen wir mal.
Dann zeige ich euch, was wir jetzt machen.
Der Stream kann nervig werden oder super schnell gehen.
Müssen wir mal gucken.
Aber allzu schnell geht er nicht,
weil ich habe zwei Themen heute für den Stream.
Das zweite ist fast noch nicer wie das erste.
Aber das steht nicht im Titel.
Das wird erst later revealed.
Ich sage gleich etwas dazu.
Aber was wir heute ausprobieren ist folgendes.
Ich habe mir auf Amazon einen Sonoff Zigbee dongle-e gekauft.
Das ist der allerneueste Zigbee-dongle von...
Ziegbi-dongle ist ein dummes Wort.
Der allerneueste Zigbee-Stick von...
Das ist übrigens nicht der E, glaube ich.
Das ist der allerneueste...
Das ist der allerneueste Zigbee-Dongle von...
Das ist der allerneueste Zigbee-Stick von...
Das ist übrigens nicht der E, glaube ich.
Der falsche.
Ich bin nicht in der Lage, jetzt richtig zu tippen.
Das ist der richtige hier.
Ja, das ist der neueste ZigBee-Stick von Sonoff.
Und das ist der erste mit diesem E-Blub-Whatever-Chip-Satz.
Der Vorteil davon ist, dass man mit nur einem Stick ZigBee machen kann,
Thread machen kann und dementsprechend auch Meta über Thread.
Also man kann quasi zwei Funk-Protokolle mit dem gleichen Stick laufen lassen.
Der neue kostet weniger als der alte.
Naja gut, also das Ding scheint auch gerade irgendwie nicht richtig lieferbar zu sein.
Der alte ist nicht schlecht.
Also wenn man einfach was haben will, nur für ZigBee was funktioniert, dann ist der alte tatsächlich besser.
Hast du gesehen, der Fabian Streamer?
Ne, hab ich nicht gesehen.
Ernsthaft?
Der heißt ja nicht mal iFreesy.
Ich hab vergessen.
iFreesy Twitch, wie heißt der denn jetzt?
So?
Ja.
Zeig mal.
Der Frasier, wo ist er?
Der Frasier streamt Gears.
Tatsächlich, guck mal da.
Matcher Audience.
Zeit fünf Stunden.
Der Grind is real.
Ja, der Fabian mochte Gears of War schon immer.
Ich bin da nie so richtig reingekommen, aber der fand das schon immer mega geil.
MW3.
Ja, wäre geil, wenn es einfach mal ein richtig nices Game geben würde wieder.
Auf das ich auch Bock hätte in dieser Richtung.
Ja, Gears, Cod ist egal, was wir zusammen spielen können.
MW3 finde ich hat so richtig reingesackt.
Da habe ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Ich glaube, das größte Problem ist,
das ist nicht so sehr für mich die Abnutzungserscheinung von Call of Duty.
Was auch da ist, aber ich habe die letzten Jahre über kaum gespielt, das ist es nicht.
Ich glaube, der auch große Unterschied ist,
dass die Leute, die heute Call of Duty herstellen, das nicht mehr aus Leidenschaft machen.
Und ich finde, das merkt man.
Das ist einfach nur noch ein Massenprodukt.
Das war es in gewisser Zeit schon sehr lange,
aber gerade zu Zeiten von Cod 4, 5, Black Ops 1,
und noch ein, zwei Sachen, die danach kamen,
war das echt, zumindest vom Gefühl her, von Leuten gemacht, die da richtig Bock dran hatten.
Meinst du, was kann man den Dingern, kann ich da draufklicken, nicht, dass ich jetzt irgendwie bei einem Riesendildo oder so rauskomme?
Mal gucken, was da für ein Link ist.
Okay, kann man da klicken.
Wir sind heute Noobs.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir Noobs sind.
Heute, es gibt heute halt einfach,
deutlich weniger.
Damals konntest du die Leute ja schon beeindrucken, wenn du gesagt hast, ihr braucht ein gutes Headset.
Wobei, heute kannst du ja auch gar nicht mehr gescheit
Soundcues in dem Game danach gehen.
Fußschritte von rechts, Gegner kommt von links und sowas. Das haben sie so heftig verkackt.
Das ist aber Absicht. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das keine, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass die einfach nur unfähig sind.
Also, man, auch ältere Leute kriegen das hin, wenn sie Bock haben und das Game hart reinkriegen.
Wo ich tatsächlich beeindruckt bin, wie gut heute, ich guck mir manchmal den Blick an,
den ein oder anderen Warzone-Stream noch an, wie gut heute Leute abgehen auf der, auf der Konsole, ja.
Natürlich gibt's, gibt's dann die Hater, die sagen, ach, das ist alles Auto-Aim, aber da werden's, da sieht man so viele Sachen, die mit Auto-Aim nichts zu tun haben.
Ja, dass da schon in...
Allein das Movement, dass keiner mehr hängen bleibt, dass in die richtige Richtung geslidet wird, obwohl es halt noch nicht klar ist, wo der Gegner ist, dass irgendwelche
Pre-Granaten hingeschmissen werden, sowas. Das ist teilweise
super High-IQ-Gameplay
in den Warzone-Streams, was ich mir da angucke.
Und, ja, gut, der Controller-Auto-Aim kommt vielleicht noch ein bisschen dazu, aber das, das insgesamte
Spiel, Spielverständnis und
Skill-Level bei den Streamern, die ich mir da teilweise in Warzone angucke, ist auch auf der Konsole, ist enorm hoch, ja.
Kann man nicht anders sagen.
Battlefield läuft bei mir. Also, ohne Mist, du kannst mich irgendwie an jedes Battlefield setzen und nach,
nachdem ich mich da mal eine Woche eingespielt habe oder ein paar Tage eingespielt habe,
wird gebasht.
Ja, Teilzeit-Montag-Stream. Das merke ich auch jedes Mal, jetzt, wenn ich, wenn ich mal irgendwann wieder in 2042 reingucke, ja.
Erst ein, zwei, drei Runden sind kacke, danach geht's ab.
Ich hab den, ich hab den Captain Poggers dabei manchmal.
Den hab ich schon lange nicht mehr gesehen, wo ist der eigentlich?
WC2 war beste. Ich glaube, WC2 würde heute keinen mehr hinter dem Montag vorloggen, leider.
Ah, ist Joey, danke schön für den Sub.
Exposing YouTube-Videos.
YouTube-Video rendert schon. Oh, da muss ich aber schnell noch mal auf AnniTheDuck reagieren, dass du auch Content hast.
Ich habe überhaupt keine Ahnung davon. Ich habe mir weder die ganzen Reactions angeguckt, noch das Apology-Video,
noch weiß ich überhaupt, um was es geht und es ist mir scheißegal, ich will es gar nicht wissen.
Nee, nee, nee, ich gucke mir das garantiert nicht an, nie.
Die ganzen, ich ignoriere die ganzen Beefs. Ich ignoriere die nicht, weil ich mir denke, oh fuck, Alter, willst du dich geben? Ah, nee.
Das will, es interessiert mich legit nicht.
Alles nicht.
Wie gesagt, der einzige Beef, den ich so ein bisschen mitverfolgt habe, weil ich es übelst lustig fand, war KuchenTV oder Shurioka vs. KuchenTV,
wo dann jeder mit den Anwälten irgendwie rumgeschrieben hat.
Das fand ich ganz unterhaltsam, ja.
Das soll ich mir angucken. Okay, was war die Frage dazu nochmal?
Kann man den Ding an 230 Volt anvertrauen? Was hältst du davon, sowas wie Shelleys selbst zu bauen?
Ich würde Shelleys nicht selbst bauen, falls ich mir einfach einen fertigen Shelly kaufen kann.
Okay.
Ein paar andere. Es gibt mittlerweile von Sonoff Dinger, die man unter Putz einbauen kann.
Es gibt noch diese Cubit Dinger oder Cube Dinger, kleine.
Also Sonoff ist, Shelly ist nicht mehr das Einzige in der Richtung.
Da habe ich letztens noch irgendeine andere Alternative gesehen, habe ich aber schon wieder voll verdrängt, was das war.
Ansonsten, ich würde keinen Shelly selbst bauen.
So ein kleines, kompaktes, ja irgendwo auch Battletestedes Produkt, weil es so viele verwenden.
Schüttelst du dich einfach mal so aus dem Ärmel.
Und mit 230 Volt rumhantieren, selbst gebaut, würde ich eh aus Prinzip nicht.
Sondern auf die Frage, ob man diesen Dinger 230 Volt, ähm, anvertrauen, was, 220 Volt zu 5 Volt Mininetzteil.
Ah, ich denke schon, dass man das machen kann.
Zumindest einmal.
Was sagen denn die Bewertungen?
Leider unbrauchbar.
Also nachdem ich nicht mit 230 Volt rumhantieren und es auch keinem empfehlen würde, da irgendwas zu bauen,
würde ich es auch nicht basteln, wenn man nicht weiß, was ich mache.
Ich denke schon, dass sie das prinzipiell aushalten von den Specs her.
Dass man denen halbwegs trauen kann, was da drauf steht.
Aber ich würde es trotzdem nicht machen.
Damals auf die Pentanuke hast du...
Ich habe, habe ich, ich habe, ich habe was dazu gesagt.
Irgendwann mal, ich habe glaube ich nie drauf reactet.
Ich habe mich, ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher, war die Pentanuke das gefakte?
Wo das Solution danach irgendwie die richtige hoch...
Ich kriege es gar nicht mehr, ich kriege es gar nicht mehr auf die Reihe.
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Deswegen, da würde ich gar nicht irgendwie rumspielen mit.
So, zumindest, zumindest was wir heute machen ist folgendes.
Ich habe mir so einen USB-Stick hier bestellt.
Also das ist der, der neueste Sonoff USB, ZigBee, ZigBee USB-Stick.
Und was man dort machen kann ist...
Tesco hatte noch eine Pentanuke.
Ich, ich weiß es nicht mehr genau.
Ich, ich habe echt keine Ahnung mehr.
Kann mich da nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Ich glaube, der Frasier und ich...
Ich, ich, wir sind über Double Nuke nie rausgekommen.
Kann mich nicht dran erinnern.
Ich glaube, ich habe legit nie ein Nuke-Gameplay von mir hochgeladen.
Ich habe das Ding auch auf meinem Main-Account bis heute absichtlich nicht unlockt.
Weil ich Nuke-Gameplays schon immer übelst dumm fand.
Weil die Nuke-Gameplays gerade am Anfang und später auch zum größten Teil, die waren super billig.
Das war immer das gleiche.
Übelste Kack-Noobs, Harrier, Chopper-Gunner.
Oder, oder, ähm, AC-130.
Und dann Nuke, bam.
Böbö, düdü, düdüt.
Ja.
Und dann gab's...
Enemy AC-130, aboom!
Unregelmäßig.
Ja, damals haben wir uns doch drüber aufgeregt, wenn Leute YouTube-Partner geworden sind.
Stimmt.
Ich habe ja, ich habe ja sogar ein Video gemacht, in dem ich gesagt habe, ich werde nie Partner werden.
So kann man sich täuschen.
Hehe.
Ja.
Ah, da waren schon mal coole Sachen.
Dabei.
Das setzt aber voraus, dass man Bock auf das Game hat.
Ja, war es auch nicht.
Ich weiß.
Ich habe einfach aktuell keinen Bock drauf.
Also, wo ich mich richtig drüber freuen würde, ist, wenn es ein neues Battlefield gibt, was ja angeblich schon in Entwicklung ist.
Und der EA-Chef das auch übelst feiert.
Aber ich meine, seriously, was soll er denn sonst sagen?
Vielleicht hat er intern gesagt, Alter, ihr Kack-Noobs, was habt ihr da wieder von Schrott programmiert?
Aber, nach außen wird natürlich gesagt, yeah.
Aber, größtes Battlefield-Team, was je an einem Battlefield gearbeitet hat, ein super krasses Game.
Was das größte Battlefield-Team aller Zeiten, was an Battlefield-Arbeit gemacht hat, sieht man an Battlefield 2042.
Irgendein Game, was den wenigsten Map-Pool hatte, wenigsten Content, so viel dummes Zeug drin zu release.
Wie noch keins davor.
Hazard Zone, was übelst reingeschissen hat.
Und eine Fahrzeug-Physik, die überhaupt nicht zu gebrauchen war.
Nur weil sie dann irgendwie...
Need for Speed-Leute mit am Start hatten.
Also, ganz ehrlich, dann lieber kleineres Battlefield-Team, das weiß, was es macht.
Aber das gibt's ja nicht mehr, weil die sind ja alle weg.
Ist schon doof, ne?
Da hätte ich aber echt Bock drauf.
Ich hab aber schon...
Naja, vielleicht die Hoffnung nicht ganz aufgegeben.
Aber meine Erwartungshaltung ist sehr gering.
Ob da nochmal was rauskommt.
Ob da noch was richtig Gutes kommt.
Der Frasier erinnert sich noch einer an unser Video, wo wir das...
Äh, RC XD...
Ne, wie ist das Ding?
RC XD...
Dieses Auto aus der Black Ops Collectors Edition ausgepackt haben.
Ja.
Unboxing.
Find das überhaupt nicht mehr.
Keiner.
Ja.
Da, wo der Fabian noch aussah wie 17, obwohl wir damals auch schon irgendwie 24 waren.
Bist du eigentlich mit der GoPro zufrieden?
Nutzt du mich?
Ja, mach ich.
Ich hatte die heute kurz wieder dran.
Was ich bei der GoPro sehr nice finde, ist, dass das Autorz übelst im Rumgewackel,
also, ich nehm aber halt auch mit 60 FPS auf, recht weich aussieht.
Tim, hast du dir in die Liste gemacht, was du jetzt in Chat alles rein spammen willst?
Da geht's ja hier Schlag auf Schlag, Alter.
Netzwerklatenz.
Da hab ich mal ein Video gemacht vor 5 Jahren drüber.
Du kannst höchstwahrscheinlich nichts machen, weil das nicht an dir liegt.
Außerdem sind 10 bis 100, ja.
Das ist von ziemlich gut zu Kacke.
Früher war 100 Millisekunden Ping, hat man sich drüber gefreut.
Zu Zeiten von Oldschool DSL mit...
Wie hieß dieser Shit nochmal, was die da hatten?
Diese Fehlerkorrektur, wo ich nie verstanden hab, wozu es die gab, war DSL...
Interleaving oder sowas? Kann das sein?
Interleaving?
Der Fastpass ist das Abschalten von Interleaving.
So hieß das, glaub ich, ja.
Naja.
Oh, genug altes Zeug.
Also, was ich probieren will, ist folgendes.
Ich hab mir diesen Stick...
Ich hab mir diesen Stick bestellt,
wobei das übrigens nicht die erste Variante ist.
Ich hab drei Sticks von denen.
Einen alten Stick,
und zwei von diesen E-Sticks.
Aber der eine E-Stick, der ist als...
...Extender,
ist der bei mir im Stall.
So, also, ich hab mir diesen ZigBee-Stick gekauft.
Also, er hat den
allerneuesten Chip,
die es so für ZigBees gibt.
Also, ist dementsprechend auch der neueste Stick von Sonoff,
wobei Sonoff nicht der Chip-Hersteller ist.
Zumindest, was man damit machen kann, ist,
man kann das wohl
mit einer...
Es ist keine richtige Custom-Firmware,
weil das ist nicht, was irgendein Dude auf GitHub, glaub, programmiert hat,
sondern das ist, glaub ich, eine offizielle Firmware vom Hersteller.
Man kann das Ding flashen, und zwar
gibt es die Möglichkeit,
ich versuch das mal zusammenzufassen,
was ich auf Reddit gelesen hab, ja.
Es gibt drei verschiedene Firmware-Pakete
für diesen Stick.
Die erste Firmware
ist die, mit der er auch ausgeliefert wird.
Da ist es ein stinknormaler ZigBee...
Wie heißt das? ZigBee-Gateway-Stick.
Oder ZigBee-Controller-Stick,
oder sowas.
All das, was man sich normalerweise in sein Smart-Home-Gerät
steckt, um dort alle
Geräte mitzupairen.
Das ist die Default-Firmware.
Dann gibt es eine Router-Firmware.
Das ist, weil man sein
ZigBee-Netzwerk extenden will.
ZigBee ist ja
ein Mesh-Netzwerk, das heißt
von der Theorie her, sowas wie Z-Wave
beispielsweise auch, und Thread, das ist glaub ich ähnlich,
jeder
ZigBee-Node,
der permanent am Strom
hängt, der
dient quasi als Relay,
beziehungsweise als Router für andere
Geräte. Das heißt, du kannst quasi
einen ZigBee-Controller an dein Rechner anschließen,
und dann verteilst du im Haus
ZigBee-Steckdosen, oder eben
solche Sticks,
oder irgendwelche anderen ZigBee-Geräte,
die permanent am Strom angeschlossen sind,
also USB geht auch,
und die vernetzen sich
dann untereinander, und dann kannst du quasi
dein Netz relativ
lückenlos auch über größere
Quadratmeter
Grundstück und alles
spannen. Also das ist die zweite Variante, du kannst das Ding
als ZigBee-Router flashen,
dass es eben ZigBee-Signale
weiterleitet, Teil vom Mesh-Netzwerk wird,
und die dritte Firmware ist
eine reine
Low-Level
Funk
Firmware. Da wird im Prinzip
dieser Stick nicht mehr als ZigBee-Stick
verwendet, sondern nur noch als
Low-Level-Radio-Stick. Damit
man dann ZigBee machen kann, oder
Thread und Meta über Thread,
braucht man Zusatzsoftware,
die nicht auf dem Stick mit drauf ist, sondern
als zusätzliche Software auf
der Linux-Kiste läuft, wo man eben seine
Heimautomatisierung drauf hat. Und das wollte
ich mal ausprobieren. Wir werden das
auf zwei Varianten aus...
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, ich schalte mal kurz
hier meine Home Assistant-Kiste an,
und mach da mal ein Update, weil
die ist schon ein paar Tage älter.
Lass uns mal
rebooten.
Trinkst du Alkohol oder rauchst
du? Ne, also ich rauche
nichts, egal was.
Und ich trink auch nichts.
Die einzigen Sachen,
wo ich, wo ich
mal
ab und an, und das auch nicht jedes
Jahr, was trinke, ist vielleicht dann Weihnachten
zu Silvester, irgendwas.
Und selbst da merke ich, ich halte ja auch
gar nichts aus.
Ich trink irgendwie so ein
Mini-Sekt-Glas und
merke schon was. Bin das
nicht gewohnt. Das ist tatsächlich, also aus den
Gesichtspunkten lebe ich relativ gesund.
Ich lebe aber insgesamt
glaube ich trotzdem nicht allzu gesund.
Ich fresse viel zu viel ungesundes Zeug.
Und ich sitze den ganzen Tag.
Dafür, dafür bin
ich mittlerweile nicht mehr zu dick.
Und ich bin mittlerweile tatsächlich,
sowohl was Blutdruck angeht, als auch
konditionsmäßig, bin ich echt ganz gut
dabei für mein Alter. Bin
heute, bin ich, haltet euch fest,
heute Morgen
bin ich nicht da.
Wo ist mein, wo ist
mein Handy? Ich sag's euch genau.
Ich brauch jetzt nicht die Sparkassen-App.
Was der Dr. Kabum
macht, ich weiß es nicht. Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich weiß nur das letzte von
ihm, der arbeitet bei einem größeren deutschen
Autohersteller. Wie es aktuell ist, keine Ahnung.
Also heute,
heute, also
heute Morgen bin ich fünf Kilometer
durch, hier durchs Ort gelaufen
zum Einkaufen.
Das hab ich, das track ich. Da gibt's so eine
Sportaktivität, kannst du sagen,
Walking. Fünf Kilometer.
4,91. Danach,
bin ich gerannt.
38 Minuten.
5,84 Kilometer.
Durchschnitts-Pace 6 Minuten
32.
Das waren jeweils 10 Minuten einlaufen,
10 Minuten auslaufen und
ja, 17 Minuten
at 5,55
Pace
rennen. Ne, 17 Minuten.
17 Minuten.
So, und danach
war ich noch eine Stunde 10, 25
Kilometer Fahrrad fahren.
Also, wenn das nicht
reicht, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Du fährst Inlineskates, nice.
Was fährst du für Inlineskates?
Ich würd nämlich auch gerne wieder
Inlineskates fahren.
Ich bin früher sehr viel Inlineskates
gefahren. Ich hab da
überhaupt keinen Durchblick mehr,
was es gab.
Früher hatte ich vieler, vieler
Inlineskates.
K2 Boa, okay.
Gibt's auch schon ewig, ne.
Ja, also das hab ich heute
gemacht, das sollte reichen. Und wenn ich
meinen Kalender angucke,
dann hab ich außer gestern,
gestern ist tatsächlich der Tag
gewesen, an dem ich mal zur
Abwechslung gar nichts gemacht hab,
weder gelaufen
noch gerannt, noch Fahrrad gefahren,
aber davor
jeder Tag mindestens
eine Fahrradfahren
Rennen Activity
plus, plus
bisschen rumlaufen, fünf, sechs Kilometer.
Ja.
Jeden Tag. Und dann hier mal
Dienstag wieder einmal nichts.
Also es sind immer so
fünf, sechs Tage,
dann mal einen Tag Pause.
Ja, also wie gesagt,
mittlerweile
ich hab, ich messe ja regelmäßig
morgens, mittags, ich hab so
Blutdruck, Blutdruckmessgerät
da liegen. Ich hab echt,
ich habe in meinem Leben noch nicht so
guten Blutdruck gehabt.
Ich hab
irgendwas, keine Ahnung, was ist das?
Ich hab den, ich hab diese
Auswertungs-App nicht, weil die sagt, so
irgendwas 110,
keine Ahnung, 110, 70
oder irgendwie sowas, manchmal auch nur ein bisschen weniger.
Das ist, ich hab, wie gesagt,
noch nie so guten Blutdruck.
Springt, springt, bringt
Spazier-, ja natürlich bringt das was, ja.
Klar kenn ich Matrix, das ist eines meiner
favorite Filme ever.
Und sonst war da Blutdruck,
wie hoch? Ich hab schon lang keinen
zu hohen Blutdruck mehr. Ich, ich hatte
vor einigen Jahren etwas zu hohen Blutdruck,
so 100,
45,
100,
oder was?
145, ich weiß es nicht
genau, irgendwie, der war ein bisschen zu hoch.
Und
damals hab ich so die, die
Minimaldosis von meinem Doktor verschrieben gekriegt
an Blutdrucktabletten.
Aber seit ich angefangen hab, mich mehr
zu bewegen, ist mein Blutdruck wirklich viel, viel besser
geworden. Ja, und jetzt ist
der echt so gut wie noch nie zuvor. Ich glaube,
und das ist jetzt echt der Witz, ich,
ich muss, ich bin, ich bin, ihr dürft
nicht vergessen, ich bin fast 40, ja, ich werde
in ein paar Monaten 40.
Und
ich glaube, ich war in meinem Leben
noch nie so
fit wie jetzt. Ich weiß nicht, warum
ich erstmal 40 werden musste dafür.
Und ich war früher relativ
fit, ja. Früher konnte ich
kilometerweit schwimmen. Und sowas schwimmen ist
jetzt nicht mehr so meins gerade, aber
dafür eher Rennen und Fahrradfahren. Ich konnte
kilometerweit schwimmen und war super
aktiv und alles.
Aber so richtig
strukturiert, so mit, jeden Tag
mit nach nem Plan was machen, auch wenn's
ein automatisch erstellter Plan ist von der
Garmin App,
hab ich, das hab ich noch nie gemacht.
Ja, und
seitdem ich das mache,
bin ich insgesamt auch viel fitter.
Und eins hab ich gemerkt,
ich hab viel
mehr Hunger.
Ich hab vorher schon übelst
viel gefressen, aber das Problem war,
früher hab ich übelst viel gefressen,
zum größten Teil kompletten Schrott gefressen
und mich nicht bewegt.
Ich mein, seriously, wie sieht, wie
sieht mein Tagesablauf aus?
Wir kommen gleich zum ZigBee-Stick, Leute, ja.
Wie sah früher, wie sah früher mein
Tagesablauf aus? Ernsthaft, ich mein,
Münze, dankeschön für den Sub.
Wie sah früher mein Tagesablauf aus? Ihr wisst, ich
arbeite in Frankfurt
mittlerweile bei einer Versicherung in der IT.
Das heißt,
meisten Tage der Woche
Homeoffice, das heißt, da fällt sogar
irgendwie mal
Bahn hin und zurück zum Bahnhof laufen weg.
Ich bin,
ich stehe morgens auf, oder sagen wir mal,
bevor ich, bevor ich Sportsachen gemacht
hab, ja, ich stehe auf,
um 7.30
oder so, setz mich an den Rechner,
dann futter
ich vielleicht mal kurz was dazwischen,
ja, geh ich runter in die Küche, futter mal
was dazwischen, ich sitz dann quasi von 7.30
bis
ja, 15, 15.30,
16 Uhr, je nachdem, wie viel los,
mach auch nur 14 Uhr, ja, also ich sitz da
irgendwie 7, 8, 9, je nachdem, je nachdem, was
los ist, Stunden am Stück am Rechner.
So, und
dann war ich fertig,
und was hab ich dann gemacht?
Dann bin ich einfach weiter
am Rechner sitzen geblieben.
Bin ich einfach hocken geblieben,
hab dann, ja, entweder was für Youtube gemacht,
gestreamsort,
irgendwas für mich programmiert,
Sachen gespielt, MMOs
gecrindet, was auch immer,
ja, du bist schon viel zu lang dabei,
und dann bin ich um 22 Uhr
oder so petten gegangen, und das hab ich jeden Tag
so gemacht, und am Wochenende,
sagen wir mal Samstag, Sonntag,
und Montag, ich arbeite ja schon
sehr lange Teilzeit,
da war es das Gleiche, da hab ich auch
von morgens bis abends am Rechner gesessen, so.
Und das hab ich jahrelang
gemacht,
Jahrzehnte kann man eigentlich sagen,
ja, Jahrzehnte
ist übertrieben, ein Jahrzehnt oder so
hab ich das gemacht.
Dann hab ich irgendwann festgestellt,
dass man immer mehr Probleme kriegt,
dass einem
der Kopf weh tut, man
Rückenprobleme kriegt, Kreislaufprobleme
kriegt, ja, und irgendwann,
ich glaube der ausschlaggebende Punkt
bei mir ist gewesen, wo ich
angefangen hab drüber nachzudenken,
mich vielleicht mal etwas
mehr zu bewegen ist,
als ich von heute auf morgen
doppelte Herzschläge hatte.
Hattet ihr sowas schon mal?
Da kriegt das echt ein bisschen mit der Angst zu tun,
wenn ihr das noch nicht hattet.
Doppelte
Herzschläge, das fühlt sich ungefähr ein bisschen
so an, ja.
Ja, und ich weiß,
wir haben total viele hier, Leute.
Ich hab schon öfters mal
gefragt, wer war früher so richtig
nerviges Call of Duty Flamer Kind?
Hebt mal eure Hand, Leute,
wer war früher am Start und sagt
heute von sich selbst, er war so richtig nerviges
Call of Duty Flamer Kind? Ich sag das
über mich selbst, ja, ich war zwar kein
Call of Duty Flamer Kind mehr,
dafür andere Games früher.
Ja, wir haben total viele,
wir haben total viele.
Immer noch, heute noch, ja.
Golden Kappa Sport.
Ja, zumindest,
ich weiß, ich bin ein bisschen
side getrackt, jetzt gerade so
normal vom ZigBee Stick, aber ich geh davon aus,
es geht eh schnell. Danach
hab ich ja noch was Spezielles für euch.
So, zumindest, das erste,
wo mir das aufgefallen ist,
vielleicht mal ein bisschen
mehr zu bewegen ist,
als ich von heute auf
morgen angefangen habe, so doppelte
Herzschläge zu haben,
mein Doktor hat dann damals gesagt,
das ist eigentlich nichts Schlimmes,
da passiert nichts davon, da stirbt man nicht von,
das muss man auch gar nicht groß behandeln,
das ist nicht schlimm,
fühlt sich nur ein bisschen komisch an,
aber das hat sich echt sehr merkwürdig
angefühlt. Das könnt ihr euch ungefähr so
vorstellen wie,
stellt euch mal vor,
ihr lauft,
ihr geht spazieren,
und neben euch ist ein Gassigänger.
Die Situation kennt wahrscheinlich
jeder. Oder,
ihr geht an einem, ich weiß, ich hab noch
ein besseres Beispiel,
ihr geht an einer Straße lang
auf dem Gehweg, und auf einmal
bellt euch ein Hund an,
von hinter einem Hoftor, wo ihr nicht
durchgucken konntet, wo ihr nicht wusstet, dass er da ist.
In dem Moment kriegt ja jeder
so einen kleinen Adrenalinstoß, so
so, wow, was ist das?
Und ungefähr,
nicht ganz so krass, aber
ungefähr so fühlen sich doppelte Herzschläge an,
nach dem ersten Herzschlag.
Du, du, du, du hast,
dein Herz schlägt normal,
und beim zweiten Herzschlag hast du irgendwie so
einen Adrenalinstoß noch dabei.
Fühlt sich super weird an.
Und da habe ich mir jetzt angefangen Gedanken drüber zu machen,
okay Max, weißt du was?
Es ist vielleicht doch nicht so gut,
für den Rest deines Lebens,
also quasi so dann,
die nächsten 70 Jahre oder so,
auch 16 Stunden
vorm Rechner zu sitzen.
Das ist vielleicht nice,
aber es ist nicht so nice,
wenn man dauerhaft Kopfweh, Kreislaufprobleme,
einem der Arsch wehtut,
whatever. Das ist vielleicht doch nicht so nice.
Deswegen sollte man vielleicht
so mal ein bisschen zwischendurch
sich ein bisschen bewegen.
Da habe ich angefangen,
einfach ein bisschen hier durch
die Pampa zu laufen. Ich habe mir vorgenommen,
jeden Tag eine Stunde
ein bisschen durch die Pampa laufen, hier so durch den Wald.
Es gibt ja, in Hessen gibt es ja,
Hessen ist das waldreichste Bundesland.
Da gibt es relativ viel Wald,
da bin ich ein bisschen durch den Wald gelaufen.
So, und seitdem ich angefangen habe das zu machen,
ging es eigentlich immer besser.
Und das habe ich ausgeweitet,
bis ich irgendwann jeden Tag eigentlich mindestens
eineinhalb Stunden gelaufen bin.
Mit laufen meine ich wirklich laufen.
Nicht rennen, joggen, sondern wirklich laufen.
So, keine Ahnung, 11 Minuten
30 pro Kilometer oder sowas.
Also halbwegs zügig normales
gehen.
Laufen.
Irgendwann bin ich dann so
hängengeblieben, dass ich zwischen
eineinhalb und zwei Stunden jeden Tag,
nachdem ich fertig war,
mit Homeoffice oder von Frankfurt
gekommen, durch den Wald gelaufen bin.
Und seitdem ging das
alles weg, was ich hatte.
Kreislaufgeschichten, Rückenprobleme, alles.
Das hat natürlich ein bisschen gedauert,
aber ging alles weg.
So, und irgendwann
habe ich das, ich habe das dann eine Weile gemacht,
und irgendwann habe ich mir dann gedacht,
ey Max,
du gehst jetzt jeden Tag ja
relativ zügig hier so eineinhalb Stunden
da durch den Wald laufen, willst du nicht
mal ausprobieren, wie lange du es aushältst,
wenn du versuchst, ein Stück zu rennen.
So,
und dann habe ich mir so eine Garmin-Uhr gekauft.
Ich habe eine
Garmin 4Runner
45 S.
Ich glaube, so ein Ding.
Und es kostet definitiv
nicht nur 30 Euro, auch wenn das Garmin anzeigt.
Ja, so ein Teil
hier.
Was ist das Problem, Garmin?
Ah, irgendwie, ich glaube,
am ehesten so was.
So ein Teil gekauft,
und
dann bin ich tatsächlich
zum ersten Mal,
ach ja, natürlich,
das sollte ich vielleicht auch noch sagen,
ich habe kontinuierlich immer
weiter zugenommen, also ich bin immer fetter geworden,
auch die ganze
Zeit, wo ich dann immer mehr vom, wie gesagt,
ich habe ja ein Jahrzehnt quasi 24 Stunden
vor dem Rechner verbracht, ich bin auch immer fetter
geworden, und irgendwann
hatte ich 108,5
und ich bin 1,74 groß.
Also das war, Moment,
BMI-Rechner,
die werden sagen,
das ist Massive-Pepo-Fett,
ja, keine Ahnung, ich stelle einfach
35 ein, irgendwas,
äh,
Alter, boah, das laggt!
Wie schafft, wie schafft
man das bitte schön, den BMI-Rechner
zum Laggen zu bringen?
Aber 109, komm.
Ich bin viel zu fett,
steht da, guck. Ihr BMI
weist auf Übergewicht hin.
Ich habe ein BMI von 36,
das ist Massive-Fett.
Das ist Massive-Fett.
Äh,
hier, die anderen Tabs sind noch da,
macht dir keine Gedanken, ja.
Also das ist, das ist ordentlich fett.
So, und das ging natürlich dann auch
ein bisschen runter. Ich bin glaube ich der einzige
in Deutschland, der während Corona abgenommen
hat, anstatt zu, zumindest wenn man
den Erzählungen so glaubt. Also ich habe,
ich habe tatsächlich während der Corona-Zeit,
wo sehr viel Homeoffice angesagt war,
deutlich mehr abgenommen
als davor, weil ich da das ganze
Pendeln nicht mehr hatte und richtig Bock hatte,
nach dem Homeoffice in den Wald zu gehen. Zumindest
irgendwann habe ich mir dann gedacht,
weißt du was, Max, probier doch mal aus,
das war so der Anstoß dessen,
ich mache ein bisschen mehr Sport, ähm,
probier doch mal aus, jetzt nachdem
du jetzt eine ganze Weile, so mindestens jeden Tag
eineinhalb Stunden normal durch den Wald gelaufen bist,
relativ zügig, wie lange hältst du das ein,
wie lange schaffst du es eigentlich,
wenn du rennst?
Ja, dann habe ich im Internet mal
geschaut, also habe ich mir diese Uhr hier gekauft
und dann habe ich im Internet mal geschaut,
was ist denn so eine gute Geschwindigkeit,
um einzusteigen, und da habe
ich im Internet gefunden, ja, Einsteiger
sollten mal probieren, ob sie es schaffen,
so acht, acht Minuten dreißig
pro Kilometer,
und dann habe ich das probiert.
Ich habe es nicht
wirklich lange den kompletten Weg durchgehalten,
ich glaube, ich habe es bei meinem ersten
Joggingversuch, habe ich das geschafft,
glaub, dreieinhalb Kilometer
hier so ein paar Mal
im Kreis am Main,
dreieinhalb Kilometer, so
ungefähr, ich glaube,
so acht fünfundvierzig
pro Kilometer oder sowas,
also acht Minuten
fünfundvierzig Sekunden pro Kilometer,
das ist super langsam, ja,
wenn man sich das mit jetzt vergleicht,
und
zumindest anstelle
normalerweise, ja, normalerweise
bei sowas hätte ich mir jetzt
gedacht, boah ey, das ist ja anstrengend,
und kein Bock,
aber war witzigerweise komplett
anders, ich habe mir gedacht,
ey, das lief ja eigentlich ganz gut,
dazu kam,
dass ich mit dieser Uhr angefangen habe,
meine normalen Runden und so alles zu tracken,
und so ein Tracking ist sehr
motivierend in der App, weil man sieht
grüne Pfeile nach oben, grüne Pfeile
nach oben sind nicht nur auf YouTube motivierend,
sondern auch, wenn es um irgendwelche Fitness
Geschichten geht,
Incident Detecte, das habe ich noch nicht,
ja, und seitdem,
bin ich tatsächlich
regelmäßig rennen gegangen,
und mittlerweile ist das bei mir so
geplant, ah ja, dann habe ich irgendwann noch
angefangen haben, ähm,
äh, dann habe ich angefangen, habe ich mir
ein Fahrrad gekauft, habe ich natürlich gleich einen Unfall gebaut,
habe ich euch ja schon erzählt,
und jetzt
mache ich das regelmäßig, sogar so
regelmäßig, dass ich so eine Art Plan
habe, was ich wie mache,
das ist zwar ein von der App generierter Plan,
wann ich wie was machen muss, ich kann euch auch
gleich sagen, was ich machen muss, und zwar,
heute habe ich das schon durch,
gucken wir mal,
was Workouts
als nächstes ansteht,
Training, Workouts,
Daily Suggestions,
heute Completed,
Tomorrow Base heißt,
42 Minuten
at 7 Minuten 5,
das ist
nicht schnell, aber
Base, so,
Mittwoch,
oh shit,
Mittwoch wird anstrengend,
sieben Mal,
steckt das nicht, ah, jetzt ist das Licht ausgegangen
von der Uhr, sieben Mal
eine Minute at 4
55,
ja, das wird, also
Mittwoch wird anstrengend, und davor jeweils
eine Viertelstunde einlaufen und Viertelstunde
auslaufen, dazwischen dann irgendwie 3 Minuten
langsam laufen, Pause, Mittwoch
wird anstrengend, wobei Mittwoch kann
ich nicht, Mittwoch muss ich nach Frankfurt
fahren,
gut, scheiß drauf, sowas generiert einem
das, das ist eigentlich ganz nice,
und daran halte ich mich,
und jetzt gehe ich eigentlich jeden Tag
mindestens eine Sache machen,
wenn nicht zwei Sachen, wie gesagt, heute war ich
normal, mal eine Runde laufen, danach
eine Runde rennen, und jetzt nochmal eine Stunde
zehn Fahrrad fahren, so, lange Rede,
kurzer Sinn, ich war noch nie so fit
wie jetzt, so,
jetzt, wie auch immer ich da jetzt
drauf gekommen bin,
das ist echt so, ja,
das ist mega motivierend,
ist
2100 brutto für Informatik
Pflichtpraktikum mit Ausbildung, ich habe
keine Ahnung, also insgesamt ist
mal 12
oder mal 14,
mal 12 oder mal 14,
ach, 3 Monate,
ja, scheiß drauf, mach das und gut ist,
musst es eh machen,
keine Ahnung, ich kann ja dazu, weiß ich nicht,
kann ich ja nichts dazu sagen,
so, ja, ach ja,
und das Beste ist,
ich habe abgenommen, auch seit ich
das mache, wie gesagt, Spitzen,
Spitzengewicht war mal, sagen wir
109, runden wir auf, und jetzt
wiege ich 88,3
oder so,
also,
um, ungefähr 20
Kilo weniger, jetzt bin ich gar
nicht mehr so pipo fett wie davor,
ich sitze zwar immer noch,
ich sitze vielleicht jetzt,
ok, Leute, ich sitze jetzt nicht mal 16 Stunden
vorm PC an einem Homeoffice Tag,
sondern nur noch 14 Stunden,
aber immerhin habe ich die anderen 2
Stunden was sinnvolles dann gemacht,
und seitdem geht es mir echt besser,
so, falls ihr irgendwelche Fragen
übersehen habt, haut es einfach nochmal rein,
ja,
und wisst ihr, was auch
sehr motivierend ist, wir machen gleich,
ich wollte Home Assistant Update machen,
das könnte, siehste, das könnte ich jetzt machen,
Home Assistant Update in der Zeit,
wo ich, wo ich laber,
ähm,
so, Settings,
Update,
brauche kein Backup,
Install, ja, was auch
sehr motivierend ist, es gibt Tage,
also, man lernt so mit der Zeit,
so, um welche, um welche
Uhrzeit man am besten, am besten rennen kann,
mittlerweile mache ich es ja auch so, dass ich oftmals
vormittags an Homeoffice Tagen meine, meine
Joggingrunde mache und nachmittags nochmal Fahrrad fahren
gehe oder sowas, zumindest,
was auch sehr motivierend ist,
manchmal hat man so Tage, da läuft es richtig
gut, ja, heute zum Beispiel war so ein Tag,
vormittags meine Runde
gemacht, dann nochmal eine Runde gerannt und nachmittags
nochmal Fahrrad gefahren und
heute habe ich es richtig in den beiden gemerkt, da ging
richtig gut was, ja,
ich musste ein paar mal, so ein paar richtig
steile Anstiege zu einer, zu, zu Brücken
hochfahren, das ist immer nicht lang, so, keine Ahnung,
150 Meter oder so, es geht dann
aber klar, so 15 Prozent oder so
hoch und, ähm,
heute bin ich da richtig,
richtig im
Stehen, also hochge,
hochgewiegetrittelt, ja, richtig
volle Pulle, ohne, ohne, dass
mir die Beine abgefallen sind danach, ja, so Tage
sind immer nice, wenn, wenn du einfach
merkst, so, ey, heute, heute ist Druck
dahinter, heute geht was.
Wie viele Kilometer läufst du
meistens dann circa? Das hängt davon ab,
was der Trainings-, ich, ich nenn's jetzt mal
Trainingsplan, ja, auch wenn's ein App-generierter
Trainingsplan ist, das, das hängt davon ab,
was der Trainingsplan sagt, da geht's nicht so unbedingt
um Kilometer, sondern um Zeit,
und,
ja, je nachdem, wie schnell das vorgibt,
also, das ist zwischen,
das wird jetzt nicht so viel helfen, das ist
zwischen
vier und
zwölf,
je nachdem, was ansteht.
Also meine Lieblingsrunde ist knapp sechs Kilometer.
Die kann ich aber
variieren. Wenn ich
ohne Plan renne, manchmal ist es auch so, dass ich
keinen Bock hab auf das, was die Uhr, beziehungsweise
die App vorschlägt, dann renne
ich einfach so, dann renne ich meistens diese,
fünf, 5,5,
sechs Kilometer, je nachdem, ob man noch die eine
Kreuzung früher oder später rennt,
ähm, zumeistens diese
sechs Kilometer-Runde.
Die geht hier quasi einmal am
Main lang, dann über ne Brücke
auf der anderen Main-Seite, und dann wieder auf
ne Brücke zurück.
Also das längste, was ich bisher gerannt bin, waren glaube ich
14 Kilometer.
Das Update ist jetzt schon fertig.
Warum ging das so schnell? Cake Wade.
Install.
Das längste, was ich glaube ich gelaufen bin, waren 14 Kilometer.
Das ging erstaunlich gut, hätte ich selbst nicht
gedacht. Da hatte ich's, da hatte ich's
aber nicht, da hab ich's aber nicht so übertrieben.
Wollt ich mal gucken, was, ob das
geht.
Max macht Krafttraining.
Ich müsste die, also, das
ist ja, auch wenn man sich da ein bisschen mit
beschäftigt, es wird ja überall
empfohlen, dass man zu Ausdauersachen
noch ein bisschen Muskel trainieren
soll, ja. Gerade, gerade fürs Rennen
hat er immer gesagt, so irgendwie,
Core Strength, bla. Aber ich hab
eigentlich, ich hab, ich hab keinen Bock. Wobei ich's
eigentlich gut verbinden könnte mit
ähm, wenn ich
nach Frankfurt fahren, äh, fahre, dann
time ich's ja am meisten so, dass
ich dort mit nem, äh, also
an dem gleichen Tag hinfahre, wo ich
wo noch jemand kommt, mit dem ich mich gut verstehe
und wir haben auch nicht weit in den Fitnessstudios,
da könnte man das theoretisch zumindest einmal die Woche
machen, aber ich hab keinen Bock.
Ich bin da, weiß ich,
ich renn lieber für mich oder
lieber Fahrrad für mich?
Ja, das ist so, wenn man,
ah, das jetzt funktioniert mit dem Update oder nicht?
ähm
Das ist normal,
wenn man nicht geübt ist. Also es ist bei mir
auch so, also man darf nicht, man darf
nicht davon ausgehen, nur weil man jetzt regelmäßig
rennt, kann man das jeden Tag immer
volle Pulle machen, das funktioniert nicht.
Ah, das jetzt funktioniert mit dem Update
oder nicht? Ob?
Ich restarte den nochmal,
ich hoffe, dass alles
klappt.
Ja, also es ist wichtig,
dass man den Großteil
seines Ausdauertrainings tatsächlich
in einem Bereich
macht, der
nicht so anstrengend ist, weil ansonsten
tut dir permanent irgendwas weh.
Und du hast auch größeres Verletzungs-
Am Anfang habe ich das beispielsweise
komplett planlos gemacht, da bin ich
einfach mal eine 5-6 Kilometer Runde gerannt,
immer so schnell, dass es schön
anstrengend war und dann
habe ich einen Tag Pause gemacht, dann bin ich weiter
gegangen und irgendwann habe ich festgestellt,
das funktioniert einfach nicht.
Dann tun dir die Waden weh, dir tun dir das
Schienbein tut dir, fängt dir an weh zu tun
und alles, weil es ist einfach zu anstrengend,
selbst wenn es so jeden zweiten Tag ist.
Und es ist unterm Strich auch besser,
man macht jeden Tag was,
aber
70% davon
nicht so, dass es anfängt
weh zu tun,
da kannst du nämlich insgesamt mehr machen
und
musst nicht aufhören, weil dir das Bein weh tut.
Aber ich hatte das auch
letztens, also
ich bin letztens
5,5 Kilometer gerannt,
so schnell
wie noch nie vorher
und das war gar keine Absicht, ich habe mir einfach
an dem Tag gedacht, ey guck mal hier, heute geht gut was
und danach habe ich es auch gemerkt,
gerade am nächsten Tag, da hat mir das Schienbein weh getan
und dann musste ich
ein paar Tage nur sehr,
da habe ich einen Tag Pause gemacht,
danach bin ich noch einen Tag nur Fahrrad gefahren, da musste ich
noch einen weiteren Tag nur sehr langsam laufen
und, also das funktioniert nicht,
man muss, wenn man es übertreibt,
dann tut einem das Bein weh.
Gerade wenn man pepo fett ist
wie ich, und wie viele
von euch wahrscheinlich auch,
wenn man zu dick ist, dann geht das ja nochmal
extra aufs Schienbein
und auf die Waren und auf alles.
So, hat das jetzt funktioniert
mit dem Reboot?
Nice, okay.
Gucken wir mal hier, Addons, müssen wir da irgendwas aktualisieren?
Gibt es da was zu aktualisieren?
Protection Moist, das ist mir wurscht.
Zigbee,
warum ist denn das hier so hässlich da oben drüber?
Aber du musst doch
ewig schlank sein, wenn du so viel rennst.
Ne, bin ich nicht.
Ich habe 109 Kilo gewogen,
108,5 Kilo,
war 1,74, ich war also massive
pepo fett und jetzt wiege ich 88,3 Kilo.
Also ich habe schon ein bisschen was abgenommen,
aber es ist nicht so, als nur weil du anfängst zu rennen,
du auf einmal übelst dünn bist,
instant.
Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn,
ich bin so fit mit knapp 40
wie noch nie vorher.
Ah, Kalorien zählen ist doof,
mache ich auch nicht.
Ja, und beim Essen mache ich immer noch
den gleichen Kram wie vorher, ich futter
ungesundes Zeug.
Wobei ich es insgesamt
vielleicht minimal
nicht mehr
ganz so fettig und ganz so
übertrieben mache wie früher.
Aber insgesamt
ist es weit davon entfernt wirklich
so empfohlene gesunde Ernährung
zu sein.
Und seitdem ich mehr Sport mache, habe ich auch übertrieben
Hunger. Das Gute daran ist,
dass ich mir immer denke,
ja, scheiß drauf,
bist heute gerannt, bist Fahrrad gefahren, sonst wie,
jetzt wird halt erstmal gefressen und gut ist.
Dann brauchst du ja auch, musst ja auch.
Irgendwie muss der Kram ja auch wieder rein.
So,
Zigbee-Stick, Update ist durch.
Also, um das nochmal zusammenzufassen,
was ich probieren werde ist,
ich habe so einen Zigbee-Donger gekauft von Sonoff.
Hier, ich hole den gerade mal und stecke den mal
in meinen
Home Assistant, in meine Home Assistant
vor allem rein. Gachi-Bass.
Und den werden wir
flashen. Ne, den stecke ich nicht in meinen Home Assistant
rein, weil ich will den ja flashen. Den muss ich,
den muss ich hier rein, hier rein
stecken.
Den werde ich jetzt flashen
mit einer neuen
Firmware und danach
verschwindet quasi alles,
was Zigbee ist von dem Gerät.
Und er ist eine reine
Antenne im Endeffekt, nur noch der Stick.
Und Zigbee muss dann in Software
gemacht werden, auf dem Rechner.
Dafür kann der Stick
dann von mehreren
Software-Komponenten gleichzeitig angesprochen
werden und so kann man
Thread-Meta und
Zigbee zusammen machen.
Also Thread-Meta
plus Zigbee mit dem
gleichen Stick machen. Heißt,
wenn ich in Zukunft mal Thread-Geräte
habe, dann kann ich die mit dem
gleichen Stick ansteuern, die ich auch für
meine Zigbee-Geräte benutze.
Und das ist sehr nice.
Das wollte ich mal ausprobieren.
Ba-bum, ba-bum. Connect to
Virtual Machine. Stream. Jawohl.
Schauen wir mal.
Ja, da ist er.
TTY ACM 0.
So, also ich habe mir dazu schon
mal ein Video angeguckt.
So richtig zusammen kriege ich
es aus dem Kopf aber nicht.
Es gibt ein GitHub-Projekt
mit USB-Flasher.
Und mittlerweile
geht das wohl
auch.
Ne, ich habe das bei Zigbee
to MQTT gelesen.
Genau. Hier.
Supported Devices.
Äh.
Und dort gab es irgendwo
ein...
Nee.
Supported Devices müssen wir gucken, oder?
Nee. Supported Adapters.
Nicht Supported Devices. Supported Adapters.
So. Und da gab es ein
Link dazu.
Sonoff E. Genau.
Flasher.
Ja. Das hier.
Genau. Da hat nämlich jemand, der
deutlich high IQ-iger ist als
wir Chat. Nämlich der Daxt.
Hat eine
Webseite gebaut.
Die über
wie auch immer das heißt, Browser
USB
direkt die neueste Firmware,
die man braucht, auf den
USB-Stick flashen kann.
Also auf den Zigbee-Stick flashen kann.
Supported Devices ist unter anderem der hier.
Und das ist ja auch der, den wir haben.
Man muss allerdings einen Browser verwenden,
der die Web-Serial
API unterstützt. Und das kann
Firefox nicht, aber Chrome kann das.
Hoffe ich. Ja.
Ja.
Connect.
Da ist er. Hat er erkannt.
So.
Ich sollte da jetzt theoretisch eine Auswahl kriegen
mit Firmware, die aktuell drauf ist.
Und dann so einen Wizard, welche Firmware
ich drauf flashen möchte.
Und da müssen wir
jetzt nicht die Zigbee-Firmware
nehmen. Wobei man jetzt denkt, das ist ein
Zigbee-Stick.
Nein. Den muss man nicht mehr
auseinander schrauben.
Vor dieser Seite musstest du das machen.
Ja. Nein. Wir wollen nicht
Zigbee-Firmware upgraden. Wir wollen die Firmware ändern.
Und zwar.
So. Genau. Das ist es.
Die Browser basieren doch alle auf Chromium.
Ne. Machen sie nicht.
Nur unter IOS.
Äh. Fuck. Was laber ich denn?
Unter IOS basieren sie alle auf Safari.
Firefox
basiert nicht auf Chrome.
Und auf Chrome ist auch nicht korrekt.
Wie heißt das? Ich glaube Plink, oder?
Ob Brave besser ist?
Pff.
Ich benutze Brave ab und zu tatsächlich auf dem iPhone.
Wobei es da auch Safari ist.
Nicht mehr. Aber zum größten Teil ist es immer noch so.
Es muss nicht mehr so sein.
Aber es gibt glaube ich noch keinen Custom-Browser
für... für... der nicht Safari ist.
Für IOS.
So. Und...
Ich benutze Brave manchmal
auf IOS. Obwohl es Safari ist.
Weil
der so Dinger kann wie
YouTube im Hintergrund
abspielen. Ich meine, ich habe YouTube
Premium. Da brauche ich das nicht für. Aber
viele Webseiten lassen sich in Safari einfach nicht
im Background abspielen. Und das fuckt ab.
Ja. Ja. Leider ist Firefox
alleine. Und zumindest kann Firefox keine
Web-API. So. Was es jetzt
für unterschiedliche Firmware gibt, ist das einmal,
was ich halt hier gesagt habe. Man kann das Ganze als
ZigBee-Stick betreiben. Das ist ja eigentlich auch ein
ZigBee-Dongle. Man kann das Ganze
als reines Thread-Gerät
betreiben. Oder man kann es als
Multipan-RCP betreiben.
Fragt mich bitte
nicht, wofür das steht. Zumindest
ist das das, was wir haben wollen.
Sollte irgendjemand mal Custom-Firmware
für das Ding programmieren, kann man es auch darüber flashen.
Also,
Multipan-RCP brauchen wir jetzt.
Ich mache das aus dem Kopf von irgendeinem
Reddit-Post und Video,
was ich mir mal angeguckt habe.
Ich hoffe, das
passt, was ich da treibe.
Wenn nicht, müssen wir kurz nochmal nachgucken.
Installation success.
Nice.
Okay. Also, er ist jetzt
geflasht als
Multipan-RCP 4.3.1.
Ja.
Can I Use ist POG.
Bei Can I Use sieht man auch, dass Safari
kompletter Schrott ist.
Bei Safari
ist so viel nicht supported.
Can I Use geht nur
in Chrome. Ja.
Edge ist Chrome. Opera ist Chrome.
Firefox und Safari geht logischerweise
nicht.
Das ist so ein Chrome-only-Ding.
Schade eigentlich, dass es
in Firefox nicht geht.
Gibt es denn Web-Serial-API?
Gibt es denn Pläne
das für Firefox?
Moment, das gibt es. Es gibt ein Web-Serial-
Add-on für Firefox.
Von
kuba2k2.
7 Bewertungen.
501.
It uses a native
API. Ja, das ist ja unsinnig.
Seit gestern
ist der Linux-Kernel endlich nice.
Wieso? Gibt es neues Rust-Zeug?
Ja, dass
es mit native Dings geht und so ist
klar, aber das ist doch auch irgendwie...
Da kann ich einfach Chrome benutzen.
Ja.
Ja, das ist blöd, dass
es nicht in Firefox geht.
Nun ja, wir haben das Ding jetzt geflasht.
Heißt im Endeffekt, wir können das
detachen
und attachen
in unserem Home Assistant.
So, und wenn man jetzt schaut...
Jetzt weiß ich leider nicht mal, wie es weitergeht.
Wir gehen jetzt in Home Assistant.
Und loggen uns...
Wir loggen uns mal auf dem Home Assistant ein.
Ich habe doch so einen Add-on hier installiert.
Für Konsole.
Konsolen-Access 130.
Jawoll.
Massive-Secret-Passwort. Was?
Wie eben?
Es ist... Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Mein Passwort ist nicht 123456.
Das Passwort
war 123456789.
Okay.
Alles klar.
So, sieht man hier irgendwie LS...
LS-USB-T?
Hä?
Wait a minute. Ah, Moment, ich muss root werden, glaube.
Äh, nicht root?
Sollte das nicht
eigentlich jetzt irgendwas anzeigen?
Was das so ist
und so?
Max Hengst und ich kann dein System mit den Informationen
aus deinem Stream infiltrieren.
Let's go.
Hackermans am Start.
Ja, meine IP
weist ja 127.0.0.1.
127.0.0.1.
Hat er jetzt den Stick erkannt
oder nicht?
Gucken wir mal hier.
Dev, USB...
Ne, wie war das?
Dev...
Bei USB,
bei ID gibt es doch
irgendwie sowas, gell?
Ne.
Wie war das nochmal?
USB, USB
bei ID, Linux.
Ach, DevSerial meldet sich der Krempel.
Okay.
DevSerial
bei ID.
Ja.
Okay, der erkennt das Ding.
Funktionieren nach dem Flash eigentlich noch die alten
Geräte?
Das ist ne gute Frage.
Also ich persönlich würde darauf
tippen,
dass die out of the box erstmal
nicht funktionieren,
weil der Stick jetzt ja kein
ZigBee Stick mehr ist.
Da ist alles runter geflogen,
was mit ZigBee zu tun hat.
Wenn man allerdings dann
den mit
dieser Software Komponente
verbindet, die ZigBee macht,
die glaube ich included ist in
ZigBee2MQTT und den gleichen
Network Key nimmt und die gleiche
Mac Behältersteil, ja,
dann gehen sie vielleicht wieder.
Da bin ich mir aber nicht ganz sicher.
Das kopieren wir uns mal raus,
das brauchen wir auf jeden Fall.
Ich werde jetzt einfach mal
ZigBee2MQTT installieren
und gucken, ob es funktioniert.
Wobei, wir haben ZigBee2MQTT schon drauf.
Hier, ZigBee2MQTT
Configuration
Log is
Error no such device.
Also, wie funzt das jetzt?
Das steht doch hier bestimmt.
Ne.
Ne, da brauche ich irgendeinen Guide.
Wie hieß diese Firmware noch?
Warte mal.
Pan irgendwas, RC
Multipan
Dongle E
Ist das so?
Ok, wir können auch mal ein Video gucken.
Dongle E
ZigBee2MQTT
Da muss man, da braucht man
noch irgendeinen Zwischenschritt.
Ja, haben wir gemacht.
Ne, das geht nicht.
Das geht nicht,
wenn man das einfach als Serial einträgt.
Weil das ja kein ZigBee Stick mehr ist.
Sondern weil das jetzt nur noch die Antenne ist.
Man muss irgendwo noch eine Softwarekomponente installieren,
die
jetzt für einen
ZigBee macht.
Dadurch, dass man jetzt zwei Protokolle
über den Stick machen kann,
kann der Stick kein ZigBee mehr.
Mit der Firmware.
Du brauchst jetzt quasi irgendeine ZigBee Implementierung,
die den Stick quasi nur
als Antenne benutzt.
Und das muss dann ZigBee2MQTT benutzen.
Äh,
ist hier in dem Video was drinnen?
Okay,
skippen wir mal.
Äh, und was ist das?
Der Silicon Labs
Universal Flasher.
Ne, guck mal.
Warte Minute, was hat der hier am Start?
Der Silicon Labs
Universal Flasher.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Wofür soll das da sein?
Okay, Addons.
Addons gucken.
Addons.
Store.
Silicon Labs
Universal Flasher.
Addon Flash
Addon Flash Based Radios.
By default is Flash the firmware to use ZigBee.
Nö, wollen wir nicht.
Aber das wollen wir haben hier.
Silicon Labs Multiprotokoll.
Multipass.
Das wollen wir haben.
Glaub ich, wenn ich mir das Video hier angucke.
Ja.
Excellent.
Okay, das brauchen wir.
Weil das ist
jetzt, genau, das ist ein Addon,
das hat jetzt eine
Softwareimplementierung für Thread
und ZigBee
und benutzt den Stick quasi
nur als Antenne dafür.
Nur als Radio, also quasi als
Low-Level Funk-Device.
Und das, was dieses
Addon letztendlich bereitstellt,
das kann man dann wiederum in ZigBee2MQTT
verwenden.
Ja, das funktioniert alles.
Ja.
This Addon.
This will restart the Addon when it crashes.
Ja, das ist vielleicht nicht verkehrt.
Configuration.
Der erkennt das automatisch.
Baudrate.
Was macht der hier im Video?
Okay, der wählt den Stick aus.
Hardware Flow Control.
Aus.
Automatically Flash Firmware,
wenn er das anders...
Ne, hat er gar nicht.
Okay.
Enable Open Thread Border Router.
Das bleibt alles so.
Okay.
Was ist das hier?
OTBR Firewall.
What?
Okay, eingeschaltet lassen.
steht in der Anleitung, das hat er hier nicht.
Ich lasse es einfach mal Default.
Show
Show Unused Options.
Okay, lassen wir das mal weg.
Alles
klar.
Change the Ports on the Addons.
Ne, machen wir nichts. Save.
Okay, Start.
Bin mal gespannt, was jetzt passiert.
Okay.
Ist es schlecht?
Overrated.
Brauchen wir den eh nicht.
Das scheint die Mac zu sein von dem Stick.
What the f...
No way.
Also ich würde sagen, das sieht gut aus.
Home Assistant Local.
Backpoint.
Also ich würde darauf tippen, das hat funktioniert.
So.
Und jetzt können wir
ZigBee2MQTT konfigurieren.
Ist nur die Frage.
Vielleicht hat er das auch in dem Video drinne.
Wie das
funzt.
ZHA.
Ne, ich will das nicht mit...
Okay.
Ich will das mit...
Ja.
Gibt es hier vielleicht noch was mit...
ZigBee2MQTT?
Ne, das hat er nicht.
ZigBee...
Ich weiß nicht, was ich da eintragen soll.
ZigBee2MQTT.
Äh...
Multipan.
Ach hier, er hat doch noch ein Video dazu.
Nicer Dude.
Ja, ZigBee2MQTT.
Genau.
Okay, hier.
Da steht drinne.
Experimental.
EZSP muss da eingetragen werden.
Aber was muss in dem Addon
eingetragen werden?
Wir folgen der Sache hier mal.
Configuration. Alles klar.
Das brauchen wir jetzt.
MQTT. Blablabla.
Passwort.
Ja, aber da muss man noch
auswählen, welchen Stick.
Oder nicht.
Da muss ich jetzt den Stick raus.
Das habe ich ja schon.
Das habe ich ja schon, das brauche ich nicht.
Okay.
Serial. Man schreibt einfach nur rein.
Port.
Adapter.
EZSP.
Wobei, ne, das ist ja nicht der geflashte Stick.
Aber wie macht...
Okay, da bin ich jetzt zu...
Was muss ich denn da jetzt einstellen?
Documentation.
Ah.
MQTT.
To use
ZigBee with ZHA config.
Remember copy
hostname of the addon.
Add.
Okay, wir suchen einfach mal nach
SELabs
Multiprotokoll.
ZigBee to MQTT.
Da muss es doch irgendeine
Anleitung für geben.
Ja, das hat funktioniert.
Ah.
Hier.
Da sieht man hier, was er eingestellt hat.
Ja, Mann.
Irgendwo muss das doch stehen.
Ich vermute, man muss
dort irgendwie die...
Aha.
Hier, sowas brauchen wir. Genau.
Ja, das ist Mario Musik.
Sowas hier in der Richtung.
Core
SELabs Multiprotokoll
Irgendwie sowas brauchen wir.
Genau, sowas
in der Richtung brauchen wir.
Mal danach suchen.
Okay, ja.
Ist da irgendein gescheites Beispiel für?
Wie hieß
denn der...
Wie hieß der Typ auf YouTube, den wir gerade hatten?
Der hat doch bestimmt noch ein Video mit beidem, oder?
Okay, aber anscheinend muss man das
so machen. Port, TCP,
dann das hier.
Das probieren wir jetzt einfach mal aus, ob das funktioniert.
Also.
Wo ist unser...
Laufen tut das noch?
ZigBee to MQTT, Config, Port.
Tim spammert
nicht so viel rum.
So, Port.
So, ich hoffe das tut jetzt.
Ich bin skeptisch.
Äh.
Moment, ich muss doch da bestimmt noch die
Protokollversion eintragen, oder?
Das habe ich noch gar nicht gemacht.
Da muss man doch garantiert noch...
Da nicht ein YouTube Video zu.
Aha.
Hier gibt es ein Erklärungsvideo.
Okay.
Wo ist die ZigBee.M...
Ja, zeig mir mal die Config.
Von einem ZigBee to MQTT.
Okay.
Das ist zwar auf Russisch, aber ist egal.
Wir können das sonst, äh...
Ach, guck mal, das muss da rein.
EZSP.
ZHA? Ne, ich bin
großer ZigBee to MQTT Fan.
Ich sehe keinen Grund.
EZSP muss da rein.
Deswegen...
Adapter EZSP.
Log.
Ja, Error failed.
Okay.
Adapter EZSP, oder?
EZSP.
Collapse Multiprotokoll 999.
Save.
Restart.
Okay, brage, dass der Krempel jetzt funktioniert.
Äh.
Was?
Vielleicht soll ich mir das hier nochmal angucken.
Der andere Dude hatte mehr Ahnung davon.
Ähm. Fuck, ich habe gedacht,
das geht deutlich einfacher.
Ja, das...
Das hatten wir schon.
Aber da hat er kein ZigBee to MQTT gehabt, oder?
Oder hat er noch ein Video mit nochmal...
Ah!
Jawoll!
Der Dude hat alles hier.
Der hat alles am Start.
Okay.
Also das ist ja wohl die falsche
Config, oder? Das ist doch die alte Config.
So, also.
TCP Core SE Labs
Multiprotokoll.
Das habe ich da doch auch drin stehen, oder nicht?
Core minus SE Labs
minus Multiprotokoll 999.
Adapter EZSP.
Ja, das war es wohl.
Oder auch nicht, weil das funktioniert nicht.
Wie sieht es bei den Options oben aus?
Ah, ist nichts dabei.
Ja, das scheint nicht zu funktionieren.
Warum nicht?
This Open Coordinator
Backup Format.
Ah!
Ich glaube, ich weiß, woran das liegt.
Weil ich schon mal einen alten Stick in dem Addon hatte.
Kann das sein, dass der versucht, meine Config
von dem alten Stick zu laden
und ich deswegen einen Fehler kriege?
Das probieren wir mal.
Ich lösche mal alle Sachen von diesem Addon.
Ich lösche mal alles, was von dem Addon drauf ist.
Slash Addon.
Ne, Slash Addon.
Addon?
Konfigs?
Wo ist denn das hier?
Slash?
Wo könnte das denn sein?
Home Assistant.
Home Assistant ZigBee2MQTT.
Ja, guck mal.
Der versucht von dem alten Stick,
was ich da schon mal hatte,
irgendwas zu importieren.
Okay, scheiß drauf.
Wir werden das Addon jetzt einfach mal uninstallen.
Und jetzt den Ordner wegschmeißen.
Das ist vom Home Assistant selbst.
Okay, Addons.
ZigBee.
Install.
Okay.
Hoffen wir mal, dass das jetzt besser funktioniert.
Configuration.
Den Krempel wieder.
Save.
Der Rest ist Default.
Okay, break a time.
Das ist noch vom alten.
17 Uhr irgendetwas.
Es funzt.
Der hat versucht alten Shit zu laden
von meinem letzten USB-Stick.
Es funzt.
Easy clap.
Okay, sehr nice.
Jetzt müssen wir noch ein
ZigBee-Gerät pairen, um zu gucken,
ob alles funktioniert.
So, und jetzt habe ich eine kleine Überraschung
für euch.
Wir probieren jetzt zwei Sachen aus.
Als erstes, ich muss mal kurz was futtern,
nebenbei. Als erstes
pairen wir mal einen ganz normalen ZigBee-Button
damit und gucken einfach, ob es funktioniert.
Und danach habe ich noch was.
Das wollte ich nämlich schon die ganze Weile ausprobieren.
Danach habe ich nämlich noch ein...
Wenn dieses Ding mal...
Das ist leider alles auf Chinesisch
da drauf.
Ja, ich habe noch so ein
Xiaomi-Thermostat.
Und die sind eigentlich
Bluetooth. Aber ich habe
gesehen, es gibt auf GitHub
eine Custom-Firmware,
um die Dinger
auf ZigBee umzuflashen.
Von Low Energy
Bluetooth
auf ZigBee.
Das geht aber auch nur, weil
Bluetooth und ZigBee auf der gleichen Frequenz ist.
Nahezu.
Da sollen die aber mehr...
Wie, die ziehen mit ZigBee mehr Strom?
Als mit Bluetooth?
Wirklich?
Egal, ich habe das noch über.
Wir probieren es erstmal mit dem Knopf.
Wir probieren das erste Mal
mit dem Button.
Das Ding ist, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob
der Button nicht schon gepairt ist.
Ob ich den nicht schon mal
gepairt habe.
Deswegen muss ich jetzt mal kurz gucken, wie man das Ding resettet.
Und dafür
muss ich vorher
mein Abendessen essen.
Und während ich mein Abendessen
esse,
lasst uns mal schnell irgendwas angucken.
Was haben wir denn hier noch?
Die gute Seele des Allersamen. Katze, Fritz,
die verlässt ihr Frau schon mit den...
Na, das muss ich mir jetzt halt angucken.
Warum haben wir hier so viel
Steve Ballmer?
Moment. Steve.
Developers.
Das muss
jetzt sein.
Ja.
Der ist so fertig,
der Typ, Mann.
Was? Developers? Developers?
Developers!
Developers! Developers!
Alles klar.
Jetzt bin ich so krass motiviert.
Jetzt geht's weiter.
Was haben wir denn hier noch Schönes zu angucken?
Budget Homelab Tour.
Was Homelab
tourt ihr denn? Jawoll!
Wir gucken uns mal wieder an, was andere Leute bei sich
im Keller stehen haben.
Der hat auch was
ins... Ne, der muss so bunt...
Das ist ein sehr schönes Rack,
muss ich mal sagen.
Das gefällt mir. Das ist schon klein,
RGB beleuchtet,
so wie das sein muss.
Eigentlich ist es komplett
unsinnig, dass es RGB beleuchtet ist.
Ja.
Ich futter mal schnell mein Müsli.
Was hat er denn am Start?
Was hat er denn
da unten für eine fette Kiste am
Start? Ist das eine USV oder was?
Zumindest hat er ein Raspberry Pi
im Racking.
Ach, das ist so eine 4 HE Serverkiste, oder was?
Ach, das ist das, was er uns
da gezeigt hat.
Verstehe.
Das sieht erstaunlich nach dem Gehäuse aus,
was ich auch mal eine Weile verwendet habe.
Was hat er denn da?
Das sieht sehr ähnlich aus zu
dem, was man hier auf der Erde stehen sieht.
Hallo Leute.
Guck mal. Man sieht leider nicht mehr
so viel von...
Das sieht sehr ähnlich aus, auch von innen.
...
Ich spule mal ein bisschen vor,
da ist nicht so viel...
Oh, MicroTik-Enjoyer!
Den mag ich, den Kerl.
Der hat Plan.
...
Endlich mal einer, der nett mit dem
ganzen UniFi-Shit um die Ecke kommt.
...
Der 3.011, ist das nicht sogar eins mit WLAN drauf?
Ist das nicht, das dürfte 10 mal Gigabit.
Übrigens, ich finde es auch schön, dass er die ganzen kurzen 10 cm Kabel da am Start hat.
Ich muss sagen, das Setup macht Sinn, was man bis jetzt gesehen hat.
Das ist nicht übertrieben.
Da liegt ein Raspberry Pi drin, den habe ich auch für einen 3D Drucker.
Einen normal gesizter MikroTik Switch.
Eigentlich einen Router mit viel Switch Ports.
Und ein bisschen, das ist echt mal was halbwegs Durchdachtes.
In der Größenordnung, wo ich verstehe, warum man sowas daheim stehen hat.
Nicht die Amis, die drei Racks im Keller stehen haben.
Was irgendwie 2 Kilowatt im Idle verbraucht.
Und auch schön gemacht mit den 10 cm.
Amen.
Es ist eigentlich nicht tief genug, um diesen Computer hier hinzunehmen, also musste ich es nach unten wechseln.
Ich habe den Optiplex nur ein bisschen von der Rückseite, was gut ist.
Und ja, ich habe hier ein paar Blankplätze, um das Computer hinzunehmen.
Der Führer, die die Kiste hat, weiß man auch nicht genau.
Da ist Raum.
Ja gut, die Amis nehmen auch eine Säge und schneiden ein Loch in die Wand, das stimmt schon.
Diese habe ich von der Arbeit bekommen.
Wir hatten eine Table, die wir ausführen wollten, und ich habe sie einfach davon genommen.
Also, ja.
Also, der unterste Server ist eine NAS.
Wie gesagt, es hat das RAID 1 Array, das für jetzt 4 TB ist, bis ich es verbessere.
Ich habe eigentlich einen Plan, hier drei IC-Docs mit Hot-Swap-Basen zu bekommen.
Also kann ich 2,5-Inch-Drohre hier reinlegen.
Also werde ich das wahrscheinlich mit SSDs füllen.
Ein paar BX500s oder so etwas.
Ja, das ist natürlich...
Auf YouTube.
Die das letztendlich einfach nur in einem Gehäuse drin haben.
Und dann musst du dann, musst du abschlöpseln und rausziehen und so, richtig dumm.
Und wenn du es nicht ordentlich beschriftet hast, findest du dann immer die Platte gescheit.
Das ist das Kabelmodem.
Fett, das Kabelmodem.
Es ist einer dieser Trash-Bin-Designs.
Also musste ich es auf die Seite legen.
Aber es zeigt mir, ob ich mit der WAN verbunden bin.
Dieses Gerät hier.
Es ist kein Droid-C2.
Also wie gesagt, es ist eine Raspberry-Pi-Kopie.
Ich habe dieses Gerät schon viele Male in der Vergangenheit benutzt.
Für andere Dinge.
Aber jetzt ist es nur mein UniFi-Netzwerk-Kontroller.
Also ist es der Manager.
Da habe ich noch gelobt.
Ed kommt dann mit UniFi um die Ecke.
Für das.
Und wenn ich planen werde, mehr APs zu bekommen.
Ich habe bereits zwei Zugangspunkte im Haus.
Aber wenn ich mehr bekomme, kann ich es natürlich von dort aus managen.
Und hier habe ich...
Ich habe natürlich das Patch-Panel.
Also wie gesagt, meine Terminations kommen von unten.
Ich meine...
Sorry, wenn ich das Mikrofon immer hoch und runter klappen muss.
Aber ich will das nicht in meinem Müsli hängen.
Deswegen hört ihr es manchmal ein bisschen hoch und runter klappen.
Ähm...
Da muss ich jetzt sagen...
So schlecht ist das UniFi-WiFi-Zeug ja nicht.
Wenn man da was hat.
Schon ein paar schöne über sich im Haus verlegt.
Alles...
Why not?
Ja, lasst die Leute.
So schlecht ist das nicht.
Ich hatte das auch eine Weile.
Bis sie mir dann zu sehr auf den Sack gegangen sind.
Aber...
Man kann das durchaus verwenden.
This one here is from my WAN.
Which is from my ISP-Router.
And this one is coming from my main PC.
These are from the server.
This is from the Pi.
And this one is from the TV downstairs.
That's actually on a switch.
So it's an unmanaged switch that I've got downstairs.
And then I've got a PoE-Injector for my AP.
I'm gonna change this switch out and make it a PoE-Switch.
Das ist übrigens...
Was noch ansteht in einem der nächsten Streams.
Ich möchte mal versuchen meine alten Unifi-Accesspoints.
Ich müsste da glaube sogar vier Stück haben.
Ein UAP-Pro, zwei UAP-Light und ein Nano.
Nano?
Heißen die, glaube ich?
Die kann man OpenWRT flashen.
Das werden wir auch mal ausprobieren in einem der nächsten Streams.
Das heißt, wenn ihr dabei sein wollt, Leute.
Hallo.
Dann werden wir die hier machen.
Dann werden wir die Dinger flashen.
Mit OpenWRT.
Und mal gucken, ob die mir damit besser gefallen als mit Unifi.
Benutzen werde ich sie nicht, weil ich mit meinen aktuellen Accesspoints sehr zufrieden bin.
Aber mir juckt es in den Fingern, das auszuprobieren.
Ich werde auch eine Kamera da unten haben.
Das ist das zweite Office von meiner Freundin.
Und dann ist das hier für...
Es sagt AP, aber es ist nicht AP.
Es ist für diesen Server hier.
Also habe ich nur diese...
Und es macht einen guten Job.
Und ja, ich bekomme...
AP, die ich hier habe.
Und es macht einen guten Job.
Und ja, ich bekomme...
Das ist übrigens genau der Weg, den Accesspoint nicht zu platzieren.
Die Dinger sind für Deckenmontage gedacht oder Wandmontage.
Ich gebe zu, machen sehr viele Leute nicht.
Ich habe es auch nicht gemacht.
Mittlerweile habe ich es gemacht mit den neuen Accesspoints.
Man kann gucken, wie Accesspoints platziert werden sollen.
Meistens ist es bei Accesspoints, bei den besseren, kann man im Handbuch nachgucken,
beziehungsweise im Internet, gibt es meistens so eine Abstrahl-Hotspot-Sheet.
Da sieht man, wie sich das WLAN verteilt.
Was für Accesspoints benutzt du?
Ich benutze zwei RUCUS Accesspoints.
Ein R710 und ein R...
500 oder 610.
Und das ist auch nicht mehr die allerneueste Generation.
Funktioniert aber wunderbar.
Leute, die sind ein bisschen zu teuer.
Ich will keine 2.000 Euro für ein Accesspoint ausgeben.
Es gibt keine Isolation für die Harddrives.
Und ich habe es zwei Wege gemacht.
Ich habe den Boden mit diesem Rubbermat isoliert.
Das ist eigentlich für Waschmaschinen.
Aber es hat nicht so gut funktioniert.
Deswegen habe ich eine Tür.
Einen kleinen Miniraum für meinen Rack.
Das ist zwar auch jetzt hier nebendran.
Aber ich höre nichts davon.
Es ist aber auch nicht superlauter drinnen oder so.
Aber ich bin sehr empfindlich, was so Festplattengeraschel und Lüftergeräusche und so angeht.
Wollte ich auch sagen, ich bin wirklich angenehm überrascht.
Ich habe ja zum ersten Mal hier einen PC jetzt mit Wasserkühlung.
Seit einem Jahr am Start.
Das Ding ist superleise.
Und kühlt as fuck.
Cool as fuck.
It's kinda hard to see, but...
I've had to use Orlex Mopads, which are just...
Viel RPM hat er nur, wenn er hochdreht.
...monitor speakers.
It basically kind of floats on those.
The case is totally decoupled from the ground.
So I'm not getting any humming through the building at all.
It's totally silent.
Die Badematte unter dem Rack brauche ich jetzt nicht mehr angucken.
I've put just some of this, like, at both sides.
I don't really have a plan for this one yet.
What I might do is install Frigate.
And when I get my PoE cameras,
I'm gonna use this as my NVR.
It's a nice, powerful, 12-threaded CPU.
It's got 8 gigs of RAM, and it's a 256-gig SSD.
But then I'm gonna install this 32-gig kit here.
I'll film that as well.
Unter 32 Gig macht man's heute nicht mehr.
...to take a look on the inside of this.
If it has SODIMM slots, I'm going to kill myself.
But I should be okay.
So we'll figure it out.
Yeah, so I'm actually really impressed with this little computer here.
Actually, it's better than the other Dell computers that I've had in the past.
As you can see here, there's actually a tool-less caddy for a 3.5 drive,
which I'd probably just adapt to 2.5 anyways if I'm gonna put an SSD in there.
Actually, I did see you can get mounting adapters that stack to SSDs.
So I might do that.
But this is kind of cool.
This is like a little tool-less thing
that you can sort of take out.
And that's your SLIM drive for DVDs and stuff like that.
Ich spule mal ein bisschen vor.
It did also...
Because I'm not gonna really need an M.2 connection.
So if you...
...so well in the full size...
...but one...
...I'm gonna put...
...working...
Okay.
Ich glaube, das Rack-Setup ist fertig.
Ja, das Rack-Setup ist fertig.
Also, man muss ja sagen, RGB-Installation ist ja dann noch auf ausbaubarem Niveau.
Da ist beispielsweise keinerlei Diffusor-Zeug davor.
RGB ohne bisschen so...
Wie heißt denn das auf Deutsch?
Ist das Diffusor?
Ihr wisst, was ich meine.
So ein bisschen milchiges Glas, dass du die RGB, also die einzelnen LEDs nicht mehr siehst.
Also es ist immer viel nicer.
Gucken wir uns den kurz noch an.
Ich hab mein Müsli zu zwei Drittel fertig.
Klar geht's weiter.
...still on the pallet.
They had not even taken it off the pallet yet.
Okay.
Wir scrollen vor.
...I upgrade as I can.
But I think this Rack will last me forever.
Like I said...
Hahaha.
Nope.
Selbst wenn das Rack forever lastet für ihn.
Er wird das auf jeden Fall irgendwann mal umbauen.
Okay, was dann?
Das sieht ja auch noch halbwegs...
...reasonable aus.
Und nicht so over-engineered.
Chat, wie machen die das eigentlich alle?
Wir haben doch letztens wieder gelernt, dass du mindestens drei verschiedene Kubernetes-Cluster daheim brauchst, dass das Homelab homelabt.
Und dann das einzige, was du drauf betreibst?
Natürlich ein Dashboard.
...accessible and easy to change out.
I love tinkering.
Probably to my...
Ich glaube, das mag jeder, der sowas daheim hat.
...but that's the point of a homelab, right?
You tinker and you learn.
So, when you see kind of like the excess cable, a lot of these things, I'm trying to figure out still their final position in the Rack.
And I've been adding a few things over the last few...
...cables.
So, I like...
...instead of aesthetics...
...actually terminate.
Makes it pretty easy as they come in to then manage, you know...
...
we did i might have had this in my last network tour but this is a tp-link tlsg 2210 mp this is
an eight port managed poe switch so my requirements was i had two ap's around the house and a couple
of cameras that needed poe power and i also needed the switch to be managed so also ich mache poe
mit meinem mikrotik router der hat fünf ports kann alle poe und zwei davon werden aktuell benutzt
für poe fertig ich habe keinen extra switch wenn man natürlich mehr braucht klar dann irgendwann
wird's auch zu viel so i was i was looking around i knew i didn't need a lot of ports um but i did
need management i needed poe and if you guys have looked at prices that can get pretty expensive
pretty quick you're looking at poes and you're looking at micro tics and you're looking at
an a managed switch so i went for this tp-link switch it's been fantastic so far i've been
running it for a few years now rock solid have not had any issues and so you'll see this is
where my routing comes in it's also uh right here part of my home assistant setup i do i shoot it in
you have a temperature monitor just to monitor the temps it's actually been interesting in
this remodel because we boxed this room in i have noticed in the winter time with the heater
running it is getting a little warm so i might have to figure out a solution
to keep this room im winter wird zwar ich dachte im sommer a little cooler going down
also bei mir im raum wird es eindeutig im sommer am wärmsten
wobei bei den amis ist ja klimaanlage überall oder vielleicht ja auch next this is probably
my oldest piece of gear i have in this rack i have had this switch forever since i first started
getting into homelab it's a tp-link sg 1024 nothing crazy all it is is a 24 port unmanaged
switch no poe nothing but it allows me to terminate some of my gigabit connections
here and then there's just one connection going up so this whole switch is on my internal vlan
so anytime i need to connect a new server or just plug in for management i have a lot of
open ports and you can see some of those are being utilized right now as we go down the
latest edition that actually took over some services is actually hidden back here i'm
trying to find a good spot for it i might need to 3d print a is this kind of a question
container
vom layout her oder
oh das ist bestimmt so ein komisches sema board oder sowas wo die amis draufstehen
wo ich nicht wo ich den sinn davon nicht checke older for it but that's a zima board i'm sure
you guys have seen a lot of the youtubers talking about zima boards but why i really like this
i versteh den sinn davon nicht this for me i installed proxmox on that machine this is the
eight gig variant um for memory and this for me like i said running proxmox and i
run essential services that essentially i need up all the time so if i'm ever doing
maintenance on my main server and i need to take it down it doesn't affect some core services and
what i mean by that is you'll notice if you can see back there attached to the side is because i
love the zima boards because they have a pci slot there is a four port intel gigabit network card
aber ziemlich umgebastelt aus so on proximущ
die netzwerkkarte liegt im prinzip einfach
auf dem Metall
vom Server
unten drunter. Ich weiß nicht,
ob das auf Dauer so eine gute Lösung ist,
ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, gekühlt ist es dann, stimmt.
Beste.
Oh, schau, echtes Müsli, das macht echt satt.
Warum genau braucht Boxmachs die Updates?
Die R2-10,
this one is an i3
with 4.0.
This has been,
getting down to the main
Oh, yeah.
Irgendeine APC-USV unten drunter,
die aber aus aussieht.
So, this has been my pride and joy
for years.
I'm a firm believer in
really starting basic.
Da sieht man mal wieder,
was ein Staubfilter bringt.
Starting small and upgrading as you go.
So, this is my Unraid-Machine.
This machine I've been working with
for probably the last 7 to 10 years.
I can't remember when I first put it together.
It's probably seen 3 or 4,
different motherboard and CPU combos.
The RAM has definitely been upgraded.
Right now it's running a Ryzen 5 5600.
64 GB of memory.
It's got a 1060 graphics card in there.
Obviously being a Ryzen system,
I needed to add the GPU
for things like
Plex and Unmanic
and Blue Iris and the like.
So, that is kind of how
that machine is configured.
This Rosewell case has 15...
Die Grafikkarte durchreichen kannst du nur einer vor allem.
Man, you can certainly do that.
I can't really see the dust from the construction down here.
I probably need to clean that off.
This case has 15 drive bays in the front.
So, all of those are populated with drives.
So, we've got about 72 TB of raw capacity
in this machine.
And then I have some pools of M.2 drives as well
for caching and for VMs and for Dockers.
I'll do a video on all the services I run
on these different machines.
This is more of a physical network,
but yeah, this machine has been
with me for a long time.
And I've actually added HBA cards
in the back to facilitate...
Ah, Hausbus-Adapter.
Okay.
Die englische Aussprache hat mich verwirrt.
Bei uns sagen die alle immer HBA.
As the drives have grown,
I haven't always had 15 drives.
Now I do have them fully populated
and I've been converting the old 4 TB drives
up to 12 TB.
Over time.
So it's been allowing me to grow the capacity
without adding a new drive to the machine.
30 minutes of run time with this whole rack.
It seems...
Or if we lose...
Nicht schlecht.
...power for anything.
It's got about 30 minutes of run time
with this whole rack.
It seems like on...
Da ist das aber alles relativ stromsparend.
...average this rack is pulling about 220 watts continuously.
And so with...
Das ist ja nix im Vergleich zu den anderen Leuten,
die wir uns angeguckt haben.
Ganzes Rack 230 Watt.
Idle zum größten Teil natürlich.
Also mein Rack braucht unter 100 Watt Idle.
Aber da sind noch nicht so viele Rechner drin.
Das geht aber noch.
Das ist ja noch zum Verschmerzen.
...that this can run for about 30 minutes.
And then I keep an extra hard drive on hand.
So there's an extra 12 TB hard drive
in case something were to go down.
I do have one on hand.
I don't have any slots in here to have a hot spare.
So it just sits here.
I know that if a drive crashes,
I will have to power down the machine
and manually replace it.
Around my house I also have a...
about eight cameras.
And I have a mixture of Amcrest
and other brand cameras.
But I really like the Amcrest cameras.
Again, I'm using Blue Iris as a VM
on that Unrain machine.
So I have different cameras here
at different points in my house.
It also pulls in from the doorbell.
And we can feed these all into Blue Iris.
And then into Home Assistant.
You'll see there is another camera on the corner.
And for me, I'm just a really big fan
of having those cameras pulled into something
like Blue Iris, where I need to be.
So I'm not a fan of cameras
that are only for my own use.
So I'll show you how it's done.
So you see, what I'm doing
is that I'm just going to
take these cameras,
and I'm going to pull them
into my home assistant.
And then I can put them into my home assistant.
So the whole thing
Das ist echt ein Setup, das kann ich irgendwie nachvollziehen noch, ja.
Das macht Sinn, was er da hat.
So, weiter geht's.
Zigbee-Stells.
Wir testen jetzt mal, ob wir ein Zigbee-Gerät pairen können.
Das Problem ist, ich glaube, der Zigbee-Button war schon mal gepaert.
Ich muss jetzt mal nachgucken, wie man den resetten kann.
Und zwar ist das ein Xiaomi-Zigbee-Wireless-Switch.
Das war eine WX-KG01-LM.
Wie resettet man den?
Press and hold the reset button.
Boah, hat denn das Ding ein Reset-Button?
Ich glaube, wir brauchen mal das offizielle Handbuch davon.
Manual.
Schadensanzeige Reset-Öffnung.
Was?
Tatsächlich, das hat da hinten ein Loch.
Was mache ich da jetzt? Muss ich da jetzt mit irgendeiner Büroklammer oder so rein?
Alter, ich habe keine Büroklammer.
Ich habe eine Mini-Kabelbinder, vielleicht geht der auch.
Ah, ne, shit, der passt nicht.
Uff, äh, ah, ein Jumper-Kabel.
Jumper-Kabel, das könnte gehen.
Ja, das Jumper-Kabel ist natürlich vorne.
Komplett mit Lötzinn voll.
Da geht nix.
Ich hole mal ein anderes Jumper-Kabel.
Ja.
So war es da, perfekt.
Exzellentes Schreiberkabel.
Gucken, ob das funktioniert damit.
Reset-Öffnung, verbinden, löschen.
Okay.
Ich probiere das jetzt mal aus.
Aha, es blinkt.
Okay, Moment, Moment, Leute.
Ah, wo ist das hier?
Vermit-Join.
Ich halte es jetzt...
Hat das jetzt was gemacht?
Ne.
Ich halte den Reset-Knopf jetzt einfach,
fünf Sekunden gedrückt.
Mal gucken, was passiert.
Okay.
Hat nicht funktioniert.
Ja, gibt's da, gibt's da nicht irgendwie
eine gescheite Anleitung für?
Mi-Funk-Schalter.
Ja, ich bräuchte, ich bräuchte da mal
ein Handbuch von.
Ja, genau so sieht das aus.
Handbuch?
Ach, Mann.
Ah, ja.
Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Also.
Schieder-Chinesen-Gramm.
What the f...
Press the switch reset button.
The gateway is just...
Press and hold the reset button on the device
for plus minus five seconds
until the blue light starts blinking.
After this, the device will automatically join.
Ne.
Ah, das funktioniert.
Okay, Permit.
Ich probiere, mach das nochmal.
Das Dumme ist, man kann den Reset-Button nicht drücken,
ohne den gesamten Button zu drücken.
Ziemlich sakt.
Wie mache ich denn das jetzt?
Okay.
Hat das jetzt was gemacht?
Also, ich bin da zu blöd für.
Eins, zwei,
drei, vier,
fünf.
Also, es blinkt, aber...
Aha, jetzt, hä?
Ah.
Das ist manchmal echt so ein Ding,
bei den ZigBee-Geräten,
das ist immer
so eine Glückssache auf das,
was von uns...
Okay, aber das scheint funktioniert zu haben.
Wir haben den Button.
State.
Ja, haben wir es doch.
Action.
Poses.
Boah, sollte der jetzt nicht irgendwie anzeigen,
wenn er gedrückt wird?
Ach, hier hat man es ja auch.
Hier sieht man es kurz.
Guck, hier, wenn man kurz draufmacht,
macht er Klick.
Wahrscheinlich, wenn man in Logs guckt.
Ja.
Hold, Klick.
Okay, funktioniert.
Nice.
Also, ZigBee-Geräte tut.
Da können wir mal kurz bei die Weiße schauen.
Wireless Switch, da ist er.
Action.
Ja.
Change to Single-Click.
Double-Click.
Juckt den nicht.
Triple-Click.
Juckt den auch nicht, aber Hold juckt den bestimmt.
Okay, whatever.
Double-Click, ja, jetzt hat er kapiert.
Triple-Click.
Quadruple-Click.
Double-Click.
Okay, mehr geht nicht.
Also, der Switch unterstützt Double-Click,
also 1, 2, 3, 4-fach-Click.
Oder alternativ Holden.
Holden geht auch, ja.
Gut.
Also, Switch tut ohne Probleme.
Sehr nice.
Damit könnte man jetzt Zeug triggern,
aber ich habe ja nichts zum Triggern.
Zumindest sehen wir daran,
der eigentliche Versuch, der hat funktioniert.
Wir haben jetzt einen Stick,
der macht ZigBee,
allerdings könnte er auch Thread machen.
Wobei, das, ha, ob er Thread machen könnte,
weiß ich ja noch gar nicht.
Ich habe ja noch nichts installiert.
Was muss man jetzt für Thread installieren?
Der hat doch, das hat er doch bestimmt in seinem Video mit am Start, oder?
Open Thread Border Router
muss man installieren.
Geräte und Dienste.
Open Thread Border Router.
Wo hat er das gemacht?
Äh,
ja.
Das war in, unter Integrations.
Nope.
Home Assistant, du glaubst, dass du das Richtige machen willst,
machst du aber nicht.
Ach, guck mal, Thread.
Ist er schon da?
Moment, woher weiß der denn das?
Warum ist das einfach da?
Ich habe das nicht installiert.
Ach so, ah, das wird wahrscheinlich Autodiscovered mit diesem.
Findest du das kompliziert?
Ich finde das eigentlich ganz, ganz gut.
Ganz gut gemacht.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt ja auch nichts richtig offiziell supporters.
Configure.
Ja, easy.
Und jetzt?
Ich glaube, Leute, ich glaube, das würde einfach, oh nein, liegt.
Ähm, Leute, ich glaube, das würde jetzt einfach funktionieren, wenn ich Thread am Start habe.
Thread Devices.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, das wird einfach out of the box funktionieren.
Das ist einfach da.
Was macht er am Ende jetzt noch?
Meta-Addoms.
Ich glaube, ich muss das jetzt auch selber installieren.
Was ist das, Meta-Addon?
Was braucht man dafür?
Meta-Server, okay.
Das können wir auch nochmal installieren.
Nicht das, was wir es bräuchten.
Äh, das ist übrigens falsch.
Add-on-Store.
Oder wie der Frasier früher gesagt hat, es mattert nicht.
Ich habe jetzt kein Meta- bzw. Thread-Gerät hier.
Meta können meine WiFi-Steckdosen, glaube ich, aber das bringt mir nichts.
Ich habe keinerlei Thread-Gerät hier.
Mir geht es bloß darum, dass ich das...
dass ich dieses Setup gerne so in Zukunft
verwenden würde, weil wenn ich mal
Threat-Geräte habe, dann habe ich keinen
Bock, mein ZigBee-Setup über den Haufen zu schmeißen.
Annet Leach, du hast
recht, das ist super
versteckt in Home Assistant, aber
die wichtigsten Sachen, die du kennen musst, ist
C drücken im
Webinterface und dann diese Suche.
Ja, du kannst Geräte suchen
oder
direkt die Menüs. Ich gehe überhaupt
nicht mehr da drüber, ich gehe nur noch über diese Suche
und man muss
da jetzt nichts auswählen.
Meta-Server
Config
Wie, das war es jetzt?
Konfiguration für Meta erstellt.
Okay, woja.
Okay, let's go. Start.
So, und jetzt müssen
wir Integrations
und da Meta installieren.
Das ist ja easy gemacht, also
da kann man sich jetzt echt nicht beschweren.
Setup the Meta-Integration
with Meta. Das ist aber sehr nett
von euch, dass ihr
das mit Meta. Stell dir mal vor, die hätten
das nicht mit Meta
setupt, die Meta-Integration.
Dann Meta, das wird wirklich
nicht. Ein Entry haben
wir angeblich.
Ne, Fake News haben wir gar nicht.
Ja, keine Device.
Ich glaube, das geht jetzt einfach.
Ich habe keine Meta und keine
Threat-Devices, um das auszuprobieren, aber ich würde
vermuten, das tut jetzt einfach.
Wichtig ist nur,
dass dieses
Add-on hier,
das da,
das sollte bitte
nie crashen,
weil dann ist ZigBee weg
und alle Geräte, die über ZigBee verbunden
sind und dann ist auch Thread weg
und alle Geräte, die über Thread verbunden sind.
Vielleicht sollte ich doch noch ein bisschen warten,
bis ich das live einsetze
und erstmal mein aktuelles Setup
weiter betreiben, so wie es jetzt ist.
Auf der anderen Seite, bei Home Assistant
ist es, es ist gefühlt alles
irgendwie experimental.
Ich bin so,
chat, würdet ihr
das machen? Würdet ihr dieses Setup so jetzt schon
einsetzen, obwohl da überall experimental dransteht?
Es hat schon, es hat
schon seinen Charme.
Du kannst jetzt ZigBee
weiterverwenden und sollte wirklich Thread-Meta
mal voll an den Start kommen
die nächsten Jahre, kannst du ohne
an deinem Setup was zu ändern und ohne den Stick
zu tauschen, zu flashen, irgendwie Geräte
neu zu pairen, einfach
Thread-Geräte mit dabei hängen
und weiter deine ZigBee-Geräte verwenden.
Das ist schon nice.
Wahrscheinlich werde ich das auch so machen.
So, und ob wir jetzt das hier
flashen, das muss ich mir noch mal angucken.
ZigBee-Firmware!
Die normale,
ja, das hier ist die normale
Firmware. Das ist, das ist die mit
denen ich aktuell alle meine
Thermostate
laufen hab. Wobei,
ich, ich hab dem sogar mal
ein paar gegiftet,
gesponsor, was heißt das, ähm,
für das Projekt zur Verfügung
gestellt, für
neue Hardware-Revisionen.
Irgendjemand hatte doch diese Firmware mal genommen
und noch weiter verbessert.
Genau, das hab ich gesucht!
Fanatics, ja.
Das hab ich gesucht. Ja,
Chatge, genau, das hab ich gesucht.
Ja. Der Typ hat auch ne ZigBee-Version
gemacht, okay, nice. Welche davon ist denn jetzt
besser? Ja, also,
ich glaube, das
hier hab ich geflasht. ZigBee.
Guck mal, da ist, da ist die ZigBee-Firmware
ist schon included, oder?
Almost two times less than
in the version, okay,
14,6
äh,
microampere.
Wenn es aber 24,7 an ist, dann
hält die Batterie trotzdem nicht
so. Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob ich das auf ZigBee flashen soll.
Weil, wie gesagt,
die BLE-Firmware hat drei
Jahre gehalten. Und wo, drei Jahre mit
so ner Knopfzelle?
Das ist schon krass. Die,
das Original,
also, das Gerät mit der
Originalfirmware, das hält vielleicht ein
Dreiviertel eher. Glaube, wir flashen
das jetzt doch nicht.
Glaube, wir flashen das
doch nicht auf, auf ZigBee jetzt.
Weil, wenn ZigBee wirklich so
deutlich mehr braucht...
Ach,
guck mal hier! Nice, guck mal, die haben ja überall
schon Vergleiche. Poggers.
Custom Power, Original Power. Okay.
Average Power
Consumption, Original.
Moment.
Das ist die Original-Firmware
von Xiaomi.
Oder seine Custom-Firmware.
Achso, versus
BLE, ja klar. Ja gut, hier sieht
man's ja auch. Also,
der hauptsächliche
Verbrauch
liegt hier, wie oft
du Updates sendest. Und ich glaube,
ich sende nur alle Viertelstunde oder alle 20
Minuten Updates. Deswegen hält das halt auch
richtig lang.
Okay.
Average Power Consumption, okay.
Guck hier.
Das ist kein Wunder.
Schaut mal hier. 31,75.
Das Ding braucht
einfach mal mehr als
das Doppelte an
Energie. Die Original-Firmware.
So, und er hat
den Reporting-Intervall eingestellt
auf, was ist denn das?
Alle zweieinhalb Minuten
oder so?
Zweieinhalb Minuten, fünf,
ja. Oder irgendwie
so. Ach, hier.
2,5
Sekunden sogar.
Ja, ich hab das auf 15 Minuten
stehen.
Ups, falscher Knopf.
Ich hab das
auf 15 Minuten stehen. Ja, kein Wunder, dass das bei mir
so lang hält. Ich hab den
Measure-Intervall hochgestellt
und ich hab, und ich hab die
Advertising. Ich mein, warum muss
ein
Thermometer alle 2,5 Sekunden
die Temperatur
funken? Alle 15 Minuten
reicht.
Auf was willst du da reagieren?
Also, wenn ich
sekundenweise
mehrere Gradsprünge im Bad hab,
da ist schon irgendwie, da sind die
Aliens gelandet oder so bei mir im Klo.
Anders wüsste ich auch nicht, wie das funktionieren
soll. Ja, also
kein Wunder.
So, und die neue, hab ich, hab ich ja gesehen, die
neue BLE-Firmware,
die braucht ja ähnlich
wenig, haben wir ja jetzt gesehen.
Die braucht ähnlich
wenig. Und wenn ich das weiterhin runterstelle
in den Advertisement-Intervall,
ich glaube,
ich glaube, das können wir uns tatsächlich doch,
doch geben,
das zu,
zu installieren, ha?
Releases.
So, wie flasht man diesen Krempel
jetzt nochmal? Da gab's doch auch so
eine Webseite hier.
Ähm,
äh,
wie ging das jetzt nochmal?
Warte mal, das, das, das ging, das ging aus der
VM wieder nicht, weil man kein, weil man hier kein
Bluetooth hat. Oh!
Shit, Leute!
Ich glaube, wir können das doch nicht machen.
Ich hab letztens die Bluetooth,
die Antennen von meinem Rechner abgeschraubt
und ich weiß nicht, wo die sind.
Weil ich
Bluetooth und WLAN auf dem Rech-, am Rechner nie
verwende. Die haben mir im Weg rum
und ich bin schummelt dahinter.
Ähm,
vielleicht kann ich die Antenne vom
ZigBee-Stick nehmen.
Keinen Raspberry Pi in der Nähe.
Doch.
Kann man das vom,
Moment, kann man das vom Handy ausmach-
Ja, aber dann seht ihr nichts, wenn ich's vom Handy ausmache.
Ist doch auch blöd, oder?
Geht das, Moment, Moment, Moment, geht das vom Handy?
Vom Handy geht? Ok.
Chatge, dann seht ihr erst,
wenn's auftaucht,
Ja, dann seht ihr erst, wenn es auftaucht in meinem ZigBee-Unschluss.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Wie funktioniert dieser komische Flasher überhaupt?
Ich habe das schon eben immer gemacht.
Der ist eine Alternative-Firmware.
Okay, das ist die, die mehr braucht.
Ein RF-Programmer.
Okay, dann packe ich das Ding jetzt mal aus und hoffe, dass ich es flashen kann mit meinem iPhone.
Oh, beim Drücken kommt dieses Gerätepop-Up vom Browser.
Ja, nee, das kommt eben nicht bei mir.
Auch nicht auf dem iPhone.
If you have a smartphone with BTL, äh...
Geht der Online-Flasher vielleicht gar nicht auf dem, äh...
Moment, wie sieht denn das richtig aus?
Wie würde es denn richtig aus?
Ich mach mal Chrome auf.
Aber ich hab ja kein, ich hab ja kein, ähm...
Da sollte jetzt was aufploppen, oder wie?
Moment.
Wir gucken uns mal ein YouTube-Video an.
Das zeigt doch bestimmt irgendjemand.
Ja.
Das ist der, der Original-Firmware-Enjoyer.
Flashen.
Ey, das funktioniert wieder nicht vom iPhone aus wahrscheinlich.
Ja, fuck.
Das, das Pop-Up kommt bei mir gar nicht auf dem, auf dem, äh, auf dem iPhone.
Ja, Safari kann das wahrscheinlich wieder nicht.
Mal gucken, ob da was...
Ich, ich hol jetzt...
Ich hab unten...
Ne neues Android-Tablet an der Wand hängen.
Aber das will ich eigentlich nicht aus der Fassung raus machen.
Doch, ich hab Fire-Tablets.
Aber die sind komplett outdated.
Die haben garantiert keinen...
Die haben garantiert nicht das hier.
Sind Meta, Thread und ZigBee eigentlich zu vergleichen?
Du kannst Thread und ZigBee vergleichen, aber nicht so sehr Meta.
Also Meta ist ein Protokoll oben drüber.
ZigBee und Thread sind mehr oder weniger Funk-Technologien, Mesh-Funk-Technologien.
ZigBee hat noch ein bisschen, bisschen mehr oben drüber, was Geräte-Klassen und so angeht.
Aber, sag mal, Thread plus Meta ist...
Thread ist das Protokoll zum Geräte-Wireless-Mesh-mäßig-Geräte-Verbinden.
Und Meta ist letztendlich oben drüber, das um die Geräte dann von ihrer Funktion her anzusprechen.
Das heißt, Meta können auch Wi-Fi-Geräte oder theoretisch kann jedes Gerät ein Meta-Gerät sein.
Das muss kein Thread-Gerät.
Thread ist quasi das Funk-Protokoll und Meta ist so das Applikations-Protokoll.
Und ZigBee ist ja eigentlich beides in einem.
Ein Bluetooth-Dongle.
Ne, muss ich nicht.
Ich hab ja Bluetooth on Board.
Lass mich mal kurz checken, ob das...
Seite auf iOS funktionieren sollte.
Was ist schlecht an ZigBee?
Nix.
Aber irgendwie sind die auf die Idee gekommen, dass man jetzt...
Ich bin skeptisch.
...Thread jemals wirklich abhebt.
Meta auch so ein Ding.
Da wurde groß Wind gemacht und viele große Hersteller sind dabei.
Aber so richtig abgehoben ist das noch gar nicht.
Also, ich setze zum größten Teil...
Ich hab noch ein paar alte Z-Wave-Geräte, ja.
Zum größten Teil bei Wireless-Funk-Sachen auf ZigBee.
Also das, was nicht Wi-Fi ist.
Und werde ich in Zukunft auch machen.
Es gibt eine riesengroße Anzahl an ZigBee-Geräte und die wächst auch weiterhin.
Ich sehe selten Thread- und selten Meta-Geräte dazukommen.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich kann dir nicht sagen, warum Thread angeblich besser ist.
Besser sein soll als...
Also Thread plus Meta.
Erzählst du vom Brave-Browser?
Ich benutze den manchmal.
Für Background-Play und sowas.
Okay, Leute. Das müssen wir in dem nächsten Stream machen.
Ich bin lost. Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich werde mal gucken, dass ich Bluetooth im nächsten Stream an den Start bringe.
Da können wir das Ding mal flashen und dann einbinden.
Ich hab gerade keine Möglichkeit, das hier gescheit zu machen.
Ich hoffe, euch hat es trotzdem gefallen.
Ich finde die Lösung cool, dass man jetzt beides machen kann.
Ja, um das nochmal zu beantworten.
Das ist ja tatsächlich der Vorteil von der Variante, die wir heute im Stream ausprobiert haben.
Du kannst über den gleichen Stick ZigBee weiterhin machen.
Und solltest du dir mal Thread-Geräte kaufen, kannst du damit auch Thread-Geräte verbinden.
Ohne was an deinem Setup zu ändern und ohne, dass du irgendwie ZigBee-Probleme bekommst.
Wisst ihr, was mich interessiert?
Gibt es Custom-Firmware für Samsung Galaxy Tab A8?
Was ist da Custom-Firmware für?
Gibt es da irgendwie...
Wie heißt das jetzt?
Die haben sich doch umbenannt.
Wie heißt dieses...
Lineage-OS.
Ja, genau.
Release 2019.
Okay, wie funktioniert das?
Okay, USB-Debugging.
Easy.
Äh, was?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, auf welcher Version Bootloader mein Tablet ist.
Wahrscheinlich auf einer neueren, weil ich das erst vor ein paar Monaten gekauft habe.
Ah, naja, mach ich halt keine Custom-Firmware drauf.
Scheiß drauf.
Die Original-Firmware funktioniert ja auch.
Aber One-UI ist so eklig und so kacke.
Es ist nicht schlimm, es hängt an der Wand und läuft ein Browser im Fullscreen.
Also nicht wild, ja.
Aber USB-Stick rausziehen, USB-Stick wieder in die Packung, dass ich den auch wieder finde.
Ja, Chat-Gip.
Schön, dass ihr am Start wart.
Ich mache jetzt eine Runde MMO-Kreise, Grind.
Wir hören uns.
Nächster Stream.
Letzter Zeit war ich jetzt schon ein bisschen fleißiger, was Streamen angeht.
Ich gebe mir Mühe, dass das so weitergeht.
Wem es gefallen hat, kann mir ein Follow dalassen.
Und wir sehen uns bis dann.
C.U.
Ach ja, und sorry, falls ich irgendwelche Subscribers übersehen habe.
Ich glaube, es gab nicht so viele heute.
Münze, HSJohi, euch habe ich gesehen, glaube ich.
Naja, sonst gab es heute nichts.
Alles klar, bis dann.
Macht's gut.
Bis bald, C.U.